class color
[Applause]
swear by almighty God
I swear by almighty God that the
evidence I shall
that the evidence I shall give shall be
the truth shall be the truth the whole
truth the whole truth I'm nothing but
the truth I'm nothing but the truth
thank you Dr kirkella for the assistance
that you've so far given to the inquiry
you have provided an expert report that
we have at 205178
can you confirm please that that is your
report and that it's true to the best of
your knowledge and belief yes it is
thank you very much we can take that
down during the course of your evidence
this morning if you require a break at
any pla any time please just say so try
and speak clearly and slowly and into
the microphone so that the stenographer
is able to prepare the transcript
and I'm going to begin by taking you
through your qualifications and
experience so far as they're relevant to
this inquiry you are currently a tenured
assistant professor at the history of
medicine at the University College
Dublin prior to that you were a research
associate at the University of Oxford
and you describe yourself as being a
historian of bugs and drugs of
laboratory infrastructures and the
development marketing and regulation of
antibiotics and vaccines is that right
yes you are also an honorary fellow of
the Oxford vaccine group you have a an
M.A in modern and medieval history from
the University of Munich and M.A in
social sciences from the University of
Chicago and you are a doctor of
philosophy at the University College
University of Oxford you have a large
number of published Journal articles
edited volumes and book chapters some of
which we'll touch upon during the course
of your evidence and you are the
recipient of a number of research and
engagement and teaching Awards which are
all listed in your CV
you were instructed by the inquiry to
address the following matters the
history of Public Health bodies in
England Wales Scotland and Northern
Ireland a description of the key eprr
functions and structures of those Public
Health bodies including Public Health
Laboratories which we will feature very
much during the course of your evidence
and the impact of the changes of Public
Health structures on issues such as the
cohesion of the public health system
information sharing the workforce and on
pandemic preparedness and resilience
you make it clear within your report
that you were assisted by others in its
compilation but can you confirm please
Dr kathella that the text and opinions
stated in the report are yours yes um I
would however like to acknowledge the
fact that peers have reviewed this so
Professor Charlotte Professor Virginia
berridge professor John Stewart and I've
particularly drawn on the help Byers Dr
James Lancaster and I'd also really like
to acknowledge the fact that I was
allowed to draw an unpublished research
and insights by Professor Alison Pollock
and Peter Roderick thank you your report
is in three parts which correspond with
the major shifts of Public Health policy
that took place across all four nations
the first part covers
1939 to 2002 and is an overview of the
post-war evolution of the United Kingdom
Public Health arrangements and
infrastructures prior to the major
health security oriented regulatory
reconfigurations that took place
following the 1990s BSE crisis and also
the 2001 attacks on the World Trade
Center
part two covers 2002 to 2010 and is
subheaded centralization and
fragmentation covering the performance
of the new Integrated Health protection
bodies at the level of the UK and also
the devolved Nations local health
services and evolving pandemic
preparedness
amidst the 2003 and 2009 outbreaks of
SARS cov1 and Swine Flu
and part three covers 2010 to 2019 and
is subheaded austerity and localism with
a specific focus on the impacts of new
doctrines of localism amidst austerity
related cuts to local public health
budgets and the influence of new
molecular Technologies on laboratory
infrastructures is that right
you know Dr kirkella that module one is
focusing on a date range from 2009 to
2020. so why is it necessary in your
opinion for us to go as far back as
1939. so I think there are two reasons
for this the first reason is that uh the
decisions made between 2009 and 2019
were heavily influenced by doctrines
which were put in place prior to this
and also by structural path dependencies
within public health systems that had
evolved over decades
and the second thing is that uh there's
a huge diversity of different public
health systems that have been put in
place historically in the UK so I think
you need to have this Broad View this
high level review of these things in
order to make informed decisions about
how Public Health can move forward
it right Dr Keller that your own
experience focuses on the history of
Public Health in England and Wales and
so although your report includes the
consideration of Scotland and Northern
Ireland you have drawn on published
reports in order to to include that
information within your report yes
that's true I'm not an expert on
Northern Ireland or Scotland for that
matter the report is a high level report
it summarizes peer-reviewed published
historical evidence and it also draws
where I can on primary sources such as
those released to me by the inquiry how
much published material is available on
the devolved Nations compared to that of
England or the United Kingdom as a whole
um surprisingly little if you think
about the fact that various devolved
Arrangements have been in place for
quite a while
um there's a remarkable lack of
comparative performance data but there's
also a remarkable lack of really
holistic historical overviews for most
of the devolved Nations and then also
particularly in relationship to England
and Wales
but you've done your best with the
material that's absolutely and we're
grateful for that
my lady has heard already about
differing types of Laboratories over
various time periods
um and so I'm going to ask you please to
begin by
assisting Us in setting out broad
definitions of the various Laboratories
that were available to the various
devolved Nations and over the course of
time starting with local Laboratories
predominantly based in NHS hospitals
carrying out clinical
microbiological testing to provide
diagnoses for patients cared for as
either Hospital inpatients or
outpatients and they mostly provide a
diagnostic Service as well for local
practitioners is that right
it's it's a bit more complicated than
that so the the Laboratories evolve
substantially over the course of the
20th century so whereas nowadays a
diagnostic laboratory would definitely
perform the functions that you have
described if you go back there's a broad
institutional diversity of Laboratories
in the UK with in Scotland for example
University Laboratories actually
carrying out core Public Health
functions which would still be
considered local
invest a lot after this actually during
the second world war when Britain puts
in place the emergency Public Health
laboratory service in preparation for
major outbreaks that are predicted to
result from aerial bombing and civilian
displacement and so in preparation for
the war the UK designates a series of
locations across the country outside of
London where microbiology can be
performed it will be provided free of
charge to local authorities and the idea
there is to have local microbiological
competence that is decentralized and
flexible to react to problems as they
emerge
you are speaking terribly quickly I'm so
sorry do you understand how difficult it
is and you're not the first person don't
worry
um but we have to remember that maybe if
you could pause after the answer
yes of course
Medical Offices of Health I was going to
ask you about
um when did they come into being and how
did they connect with the emergency
Public Health laboratory service that
you've described
the Office of Medical Offices of Health
emerges in the 19th century and it is
one of the first key offices of Public
Health in the UK the medical officer is
in charge of infectious disease
investigation and control it's also
increasingly important
the form of reporting of diseases the
role evolves quite a bit for a while
they run their own hospitals at the
local level they integrate a variety of
services but after the second world war
they form part of
a tripartite function of the new
National Health Service and this is a
similar function across nearly all UK
Nations where they function as the
central part of call for public health
at the local level and can draw on there
what then becomes the public health
laboratory service or the various other
microbiological services well
indeed did the emergency Public Health
laboratory service then
which we
along
see solution becomes permanent
did it start off as an integrated
network of 19 Laboratories across
England and Wales
but by 1969 had the number of phls
Laboratories grown to 63. yes and many
of the new Laboratories were located
within local hospitals yes
now I'd like to display please a a
figure that comes from your article
called Giants on Clay feet which is at
207 449 we can see that here
um and if we go to page 17 and zoom in
to figure one
just to familiarize ourselves with these
four charts and are the red dots
representing local Laboratories and the
black dots representing Regional
Laboratories yes the distinctions vary
over time but I think between 1946 and
1965 that's that's a very accurate
description
looking at figure a we can see that um
at the north of uh
there are mainly local Laboratories but
in the South they are mainly Regional
Laboratories and we can see that there
is a blue square around the greater
London area which is blown up and
depicted in figure B so we can see that
there were a number 10 in number I think
of Laboratories in the greater London
area would you have described those as
local or Regional Laboratories the
London Laboratories were technically not
part of the emergency Public Health
laboratory service but of the Emergency
Medical Service however they did
contribute to the overall
microbiological intelligence gathering
so again over historical time periods of
almost a century the distinctions vary
and blurb it
that by 1946 there were a significantly
larger number of both local and Regional
Laboratories and by 1960
Laboratories but around about the same
number if not slightly fewer of of
regional Laboratories now configurated
in the Northwest and the the sort of
Southern belt or or the southern
Midlands belt of of England
um
there was no formal requirement to send
samples or report disease outbreaks to
the public health laboratory service
that's correct um the idea behind this
was very simple this service was
designed to slot into existing public
health services without disrupting them
so the idea was you would provide free
testing services free epidemiological
expertise without stepping on anybody's
administrative toes at the local level
and by 1972 you tell us in your report
that the successful integration of local
public health and Health Services
was unparalleled in Western Europe or
North America there is no comparable
Public Health laboratory Network all
right thank you we can take that down
now
moving to a slightly later period in
1974 was there a major reorganization of
the NHS and local Authority Services
which led to the abolition of the role
of medical officers of Health
yes
why were they abolished at that time
there were concerns about the
performance of medical officers of
Health that the service had become
overstretched I believe there were 550
officers spread over
1244 local authorities so that led to
concerns both about the overstretch
service and this was also a time when
there was significant political desire
to reform and make the NHS more
efficient and as a consequence also of
the epidemiological shift which we're
seeing where people are no longer
primarily dying of infectious diseases
but of non-infectious diseases there's
also a relative de-emphasis on the
infection control
our duties and that that the moh you
know had had done previously so it's a
constant
of the day is that
um this this integrating focal points of
Public Health at the local level
disappears and it's very difficult to
replace
in 1988 a report by the then chief
medical officer Donald hson led to
further significant changes didn't it
and each health authority was then to
employ a consultant in communicable
disease control or a CCDC who was
accountable to the newly created office
of
director of Public Health and that's
something that we recognize in the
inquiry because my lady has heard
evidence about that role before this
morning
and the regional dphs or directors of of
Public Health would coordinate Health
protection across the districts or their
regions and Report annually on the
health of the population in the area
that they served is that right that's
correct
just pausing and and remaining for a
moment on the on the situation of
Laboratories though the 1970s had seen
11 of the public health laboratory
service Laboratories close and by the
early 1980s competition for limited
Public Health Resources amidst a growing
emphasis as you've said on
non-communicable diseases and
led to cost cutting reviews and posed
what you describe as a threat to the
whole system is that right yes
from the 1990s onwards the public health
laboratory service had sole management
of the Laboratories and charged Health
authorities and GPS for diagnostic tests
is that right that's correct how did
that formalized charging Arrangement
impact the relationship between the
public health laboratory service and the
NHS
it significantly complicated the very
effective yet quite informal
Arrangements of the possible period you
have to imagine Public Health especially
at the local level as a bricks and
mortar infrastructure where people knew
where to go it was clear that there was
an anchor Point within the phls that
local Anchor Point was integrated into a
national network and often there were
informal economies of intelligence
gathering so as a as a microbiologist
you would speak to your local clinician
you would know what was going on you
would also speak prior to the abolition
to the moh so it was a very Dynamic
horizontally integrated system that was
still vertically connected upwards
especially after the actress and reforms
with the ability to search if there were
outbreaks going forward the idea of the
internal markets that's introduced in
the 1990s was that you would create
efficiency in the system by making the
system perform according to Market rules
problem was however with the phls that
charging for every single service in
many ways destroys these informal
economies of exchange it incentivizes
the NHS and other providers perhaps to
go with private providers or it
incentivizes perhaps less testing and
less reporting so the phls was
struggling during this time all right
moving forward a few years to the mid to
late 1990s the phls was divided into 10
Regional groups with devolved budgets
and that number of groups was reduced to
eight by 2002.
at which point the Welsh Public Health
Arrangements diverged significantly
didn't they from those in England yes
that's a result of a major reordering
actually might the English level than at
the Welsh level well let's now deal with
each of the four nations independently
please starting with England and the
time period 2002 to 2010.
you tell us in your report that the
Blair government made significant
reforms to help
in
to focus on during this period are the
establishment of the health Protection
Agency the transfer of control of the pH
LS local public health Laboratories to
the NHS
establishment of the health Protection
Agency as a painful birth and that staff
described the integration at that time
as challenging
which perhaps isn't surprising given
that it fused into a single entity 80
organizations in 140 locations and 400
distinct I.T applications with 40 to 50
websites
it was estimated was it not that it
would take up to five years to fully
integrate all HPA services and did that
prove to be the case Dr kafella
um so the painful birth is a quote from
from Witnesses at the time actually it's
from the first executive
very quickly just into to why the HPA
was created in the first place yes
please and this was an attempt to move
and fundamentally reform Public Health
reporting to a more Upstream function of
intelligence gathering and coordination
there had been long-standing complaints
about parallel hierarchies and
competition between the NHS and public
health laboratory provision at the local
level and following the 9 11 attacks but
also following a request by the UK's
government the then UK CMO Liam
Donaldson
reconceptualize Health protection in a
very American cdc-led style where you
would integrate and combine
responsibilities for infection control
radioactive and chemical Hazard control
into one big agency that could in a kind
of command and control system gather the
intelligence and swoop in and help
should there be problems at the local
level now as you've already referred to
it's an organizational Behemoth in
contrast to the initial infection
control infrastructures and the painful
nature of the birth also results from
the fact that there are very strong
distinct identities within these
organizations which are all being
integrated so what you have witnesses
describing is an extreme territoriality
of different departments vying for
resources within the HPA and at the same
time you have I think
just a significant organizational
challenge it was set up within a matter
of months there was not years of
preparation for this setup for things to
work so it was running from 2003 whether
the functions were perfect I think that
Witnesses agree that there were
significant issues right
in terms of the transfer of the local
public health Laboratories let's just
return if if we can please to your
Giants on Clay feet report and look at
another
set of figures
um showing as we can see in the
description at the bottom of this page
the extent of laboratory networks under
the public health laboratory service in
1980 and then the HPA in 2010
now what do we see
um happening in in 1980 and take us
through how that has transitioned by the
time we get to 2010 please so in 1980
you already see a slightly slimmed down
version of the post-war arrangement of
Public Health in England and Wales we're
not talking about Scotland and Northern
Ireland here yes it's a very networked
infrastructure of Public Health
Laboratories with regional centers that
collate information and a very strong
National reference system in colindale
in North London which is now the
headquarters also of ukhsa
in 2010 what you see is the result of
this attempt to make Health protection
Upstream
funding a way of the local
infrastructure of Public Health
Laboratories to the NHS
the microbiology service which take over
the running of those local labs and a
very significant limitation of dedicated
Public Health laboratory capacity into
these Regional labs and London actually
has two of these of these specialist
centers right so so what we see by 2010
is
nine only
what you would describe as Regional
Laboratories we can I know that there
are only eight dots on the page but
you've said that there are two there are
two of them that's a feature of the
mapping all right and how did that
affect the service that was
able to be provided
the ideal of the service was again
slimmed down and efficient so you would
have Regional teams which would have
provide local pcts or Primary Care
trusts with advice they would also be
able to commission more detailed Public
Health work from NHS Laboratories but
the idea was that the expertise would be
condensed in Regional centers which
would also provide epidemiologists and
epidemic intelligence to counter out
Laboratories at the time with colindale
functioning as essentially the hearts or
the brain of the UK
of Public Health that's not unique to
the UK this is something many other
countries are doing at this time but
this is this idea of creating a kind of
top heavy slimmed down rapid response
command and control architecture that is
quite different actually from the
architecture of emergency that was
predominant during the second World War
is there a difference between a
specialist and Reference Laboratory and
a public health Laboratory
I mean both are within the Public Health
Service a specialist laboratory will be
able to perform as the name says
specialist tests and likely also have
higher security clearance for specific
groups of pathogens
right you describe in your report that
the dissolution of local phls structures
was traumatic why do you describe it as
such
again um I quote so uh this is this is
um the the words of the contemporaries
um a large part of the phls workforce
was obviously located in these local
Laboratories they had existed for
decades and had an extremely strong
identity and suddenly these Laboratories
were transferred to the NHS very
different employment system and the phls
was
against the will essentially of the
boards fused with a much larger agency
and for members of the phls if you look
at the witness seminars of the time it
is described as traumatic and and very
turbulent with lots of confusion with
between lots of different systems and
also within the HPA
what about Primary Care trusts their
creation and and the intention that they
would improve or provide a a health
Improvement role and how did they come
about and and how was that change
received so I can't I think I think
talking through the history of the
overall blairite reforms of the NHS
would be paths too too big now but the
idea of the pcts is to unify and to make
health and public health more efficient
at the local level by integrating
various functions including the health
Improvement function interestingly
however the proper officer so you know
what previously used to be the moh and
then was the CCDC
HPA so the CCDC is employed by the HPA
with these Regional teams rather than
being anchored at this local Nexus
within the pcts and I'm sure we'll talk
about the pandemic responses it causes
all manner of confusion where this
function is located within the
administrative system
so organizational change on a large
scale
in terms of government support for the
newly formed HPA you describe in your
report that over this period of time
that was somewhat erratic because it had
received a hundred and sixteen million
pounds of funding from the Department of
Health in 2013 that was its first year
in existence then that Rose to 193
million
um
I'm so sorry not not 2013 in in
2003 and then that Rose to 193 million
following the 2009 swine flu outbreak
and then went back down to 142 million
in the
2012-2013 budgetary year and and that
differing rise and fall was also
mirrored in stuffing levels wasn't it so
did that in itself cause a level of
confusion
I think this is a classic example of
yo-yo funding for public health in an
outside crisis so once the immediate
perception of a crisis is passed funding
tends to go down within the HPA
um
it's it's difficult to comment on
whether the funding itself led to
confusion I think it certainly made it
difficult to plan for resilience
capability building if there were these
huge fluctuations in funding
thank you
I'd like to move now to the the period
of time that this inquiry is is
concerned with and it's really 2009 or
10 up to the time that that kovid hit
you describe in your report that in 2012
in England we saw the most complex
political restructuring of health and
public health services that had happened
in decades or perhaps ever
the primary care trusts were abolished
and public health competencies were
transferred back to local authorities as
had been the case before their creation
and now we see that the HPA was replaced
by what is described as a super
organization in the form of Public
Health England
what was the rationale for making these
significant and complex changes
so in the case of Public Health England
the irrational is to integrate Health
protection and health Improvement
functions the English reforms actually
come after similar reforms in the
devolved Administration so Health
Improvement during this time is becoming
very big in international health and the
UK is in line with the trends there at
the local level the idea here is and
this is quoting
void and overcome what is perceived to
be a structurally inefficient structure
of the pcts and also to
empower local authorities to tackle poor
health outcomes with their local
knowledge the assumption is local people
know best what the local problems are so
if you devolve power to them they will
be best able to spend money rationally
to take care of this
despite those intentions was there at
first at least blurred statutory overlap
between local Authority Secretary of
State and the Civil contingencies act
duties and I think you describe it in in
the following terms what sounded
complicated on paper proved complicated
in practice
that's true I think I spent on this page
I spent probably the most time per page
to get my head around who was
responsible for what and I think the
inquiry has shown the famous spaghetti
chart
this I can I would prefer to read the
report itself so that I don't get it
wrong it's so complicated all right well
we'll we'll turn to to do that in in a
short while but in in a by way of a very
high level summary
um Public Health England combined
previously distinct health organizations
Health protection and promotion
functions brought all of those together
which involved emerging of 5 000 staff
from 120 organizations yes
and although it absorbed many
pre-existing structures it also differed
from its predecessors in key ways
firstly as we've just mentioned the
combination of Health protection and
health promotion
but didn't it also break with post 1950s
English traditions of of statutory
non-departmental Public Health bodies
because Public Health England became
effectively an executive body as the
inquiry has already heard within the
Department of Health
that in itself resulted in what you
describe in your report as far greater
political control over Public Health
activities by its ministers
and also meant that the employees of
Public Health England were effectively
civil servants and subject to the
official Secrets Act yes
was that a cause for concern that was a
significant cause of concern ahead of
the dissolution of HPA but also after
the creation of phe
um I know that Jenny Harris has also
commented on the Independence that she
still perceives PhD had
what the historical investigation shows
is that senior microbiologists HPA
officials
have consistent concerns about what this
might do
in terms of Public Health agencies
ability to speak openly to power
ahead of the transformation the BMA
surveys its members within the phe
establishment in 2014 they themselves
it's
later on local Health authorities polled
by ipsos Mori say that they feel that
phe could do more to lobby for public
health protection to the Department of
Health so there are numerous different
points of evidence which I think paint
is slightly more complicated picture
than perhaps Duncan Selby or Jenny
Harris have said
just touching upon Duncan Selby as you
mentioned him and the fact that he had
at the time that he took over as chief
executive of Public Health England no
scientific or medical background and he
explained in his evidence to my lady
that despite that and the we talked
about the the
um light-hearted way in which that was
dealt with in in the Lancet article
um despite that he felt that he had
sufficient experience in the roles that
he had fulfilled prior to taking over
the chief executive role so that his
lack of medical and scientific knowledge
did not create any difficulty
do do you think that it is a problem
that the chief executive of Public
Health England was neither qualified in
science or medicine
let me phrase it this way
um it's remarkable that for 70 years the
UK decided to have a medically qualified
and scientifically expert executive of
the most important public health agency
consistently and it's also interesting
that the choice for ukhsa seems to have
gone in the same direction I admire
Duncan Selby's statement for its
frankness and I think honestly I think
that it is interesting to see how you
would be able to communicate complex
scientific information
to ministers in meetings as the de facto
head of the public health establishment
I have no doubt about the managerial
expertise but I do think that if you
look at the statements of previous
Public Health laboratory service
directors and HPA directors you will see
that there was substantial effort that
they also had to do to communicate the
science effectively
2012 reforms about which my lady has
heard and the creation of Public Health
England evoked mixed responses from the
English Public Health Community as we've
touched upon and when Dame Jenny Harris
gave evidence I took her through five
issues which are also dealt with in your
report and I'm going to ask you about
now Dr thefella
one confusion over eprr responsibilities
to Independents from government which
we've already touched upon three funding
issues
four capacity issues and five
fragmentation of the services
so in terms of the first of these topics
confusion over eprr responsibilities
Dame Jenny agreed that there was some
confusion over those responsibilities
arising out of what she described as a
complicated overlapping or blurred state
of statutory responsibilities and
although she agreed that it wasn't a
perfect system
before
there was a a level of confusion when
Public Health England was first created
however she said that whenever there's
any level of structural change there
will be a bedding in period during which
there's confusion do you agree with that
of course I mean I think the the sailing
question to ask is how long the
confusion lasts for and if we look at
the preparedness exercises if we look at
all of the statements that we have from
internal reviews of Public Health and
they are cited in the report you see
that this confusion is remarkably
persistent so you would expect that
after let's say seven years after the
setting up of an agency the confusion
would die down
and unfortunately I think in the
documents you see that that is not
necessarily the case
I'd like to turn to funding please and
display your report at page 72 paragraph
108.
thank you and we can read through this
together functioning of the new local
and National English Public Health
structures was compromised by austerity
politics at the local level the
abolition of public Primary Care trusts
meant that overall Public Health
performance was strongly dependent on
local Authority capabilities to
commission and deliver effective
Services ministers had promised to ring
fence the public health budget for local
authorities however an in-year cut of
200 million pounds in 2015 was followed
by further reductions over the next five
years
according to the local government
Association this amounted to a real-term
reduction of the public health Grant
from over 3.5 billion pounds in 2015 to
16 to just over 3 billion pounds in
2020-21 that's a reduction of 14 percent
other estimates by The Institute for
Public Policy research spoke of an even
more dramatic reduction of 850 million
pounds in net expenditure between
2014-15 and 2019-20 with the poorest
areas of England experiencing
disproportionately High cuts of almost
15 percent
resulting pressures on local public
health were exacerbated by an overall 49
real-term cut in central government
funding for local authorities between
2010-11 and 2016-17 and a resulting
practice of top slicing whereby
authorities reallocated ring fenced
Public Health budgets to other services
broadly impacting health and well-being
such as trading standards or parks and
green spaces in 2010 healthy lives
healthy people had promised to give
local government the freedom
responsibility and funding to innovate
and develop their own ways of improving
Public Health in their area freedom and
responsibility had been granted but
funding was often lacking
now Dame Jenny when she gave evidence
agreed that the ring fenced Public
Health budget reduced over time due to
austerity and she said that she
recognized some of the figures that
appear in your report but she went on to
say that there are 152 top-tier local
authorities and a 200 million pounds cut
in the year well that's about a million
each across the various local
authorities and whilst she agreed that
the directors of Public Health were
under significant pressure she added
that the local authorities were actually
very efficient in commissioning services
and so could generate savings to
mitigate the loss do you agree with that
interpretation
I I would disagree with with parts of it
I think Duncan Selby has put it
eloquently that a one million pound cut
for a local Authority is a significant
cut and can result in the closure of a
crucial Health Center or of other
crucial Services we see this with the
top slicing
there's also a difference in my opinion
between managing Cuts efficiently and
building resilience and building
capacity for public health so are we
managing a decline or are we
administering Public Health in terms of
the goals of improving Health outcomes
in terms of Workforce capacity issues we
can take that down thank you
Dame Jenny Harris told the inquiry that
um
lots of stuff were lost in the move to
Public Health England because
in part at least there was a change in
the hierarchy within the local Authority
rules in other words with the with the
um with some of the directors of Public
Health roles there was a feeling that
they were reduced really in in terms of
their importance and so that that led to
a certain amount of loss of Workforce
capacity and and in addition to that and
particularly uh from the smaller local
authorities
um there were was a reduction in stuff
is that something which which you
recognized during the change taking
place
um yes but just to clarify that phe
would not be the dph post right that
would be the local Authority now right
um so I think at both levels there is as
with any big organizational change quite
a significant turmoil there are early
retirements which result again and we
see this every time a major reform
occurs a loss of expertise people go
into early retirement knowledge and
competence is lost over time and I
believe at some point in the report I
quote the figure that 17 at some point
of local director of Public Health posts
were vacant yes this is compensated over
time but if you think think about this
as a process that is less than a decade
long before the pandemic hits that is
quite a lot of organizational turmoil at
the local level anodes at the national
level to compensate for when you are
also tasked with providing resilience
you also tell us in your report that by
2021 I appreciate we're moving forwards
now 69 of the service medical Workforce
were located in the newly established UK
HSA the office of
um Health Improvement and disparities
the ohid and the NHS and of non-clinical
Specialists which include the majority
of directors of Public Health and
Consultants
90 percent were in local authorities and
largely concerned with health promotion
so that shift in your view inevitably
compromised local level local level
infection control capabilities is that
right it's an exacerbation of a longer
term Trend that starts earlier but I
think does gather Steam and this is
based on research for the infected blood
inquiry that Alice and Pollock and Peter
Roderick and James Lancaster did all
right let's go back to your report at
paragraph 110 please which is at page
74.
drawing these threads together thank you
you say austerity and Workforce
pressures also impacted Public Health
England ahead of the formation of the
new agency a 2012 strategy paper had
warned of Workforce attrition while
simultaneously setting out an ambitious
vision of maintaining and expanding
surveillance capabilities sorry
capacities as well as of improving
oversight and network integration the
vision was difficult to fulfill although
regular polling of local authorities
indicated that phe's staff expertise
data and services were highly valued and
that appreciation increased over time
phe experienced cuts of core funding
in 2013 to 14 phe had received a
non-ring-fenced revenue for operating
expenses of 405 million pounds by 2018
to 19 operating activities were priced
at
395.8 million pounds which amounted to
an over to an over nine percent budget
fall since 2013 to 14 in real terms
although allocation of funds for
Infectious Disease Control Rose during
this period the number of Staff employed
for the protection from infectious
disease fell
from
2397 to
2093 a fall of 12.7 percent whilst those
employed in environmental hazards
protection and emergency preparedness
fell from 517 to 476 which was a fall of
7.9 percent
Dame Jenny told the inquiry that almost
all public sector organizations had had
budget decreases around this time but of
course the combined effect of that meant
that if the local Authority also had
insufficient and the NHS had also
dropped their numbers of Staff what
happened was in her view when you met
around the local resilience Forum table
you may not see the person you saw last
week because they'd gone to another
position did you recognize that in her
evidence and and did you recognize that
as a problem
I agree with the evidence you also see
it in the tabletop exercises in the
departmental reviews of phe where it's
noted that the pondons so the
corresponding people in other
administrations are increasingly
difficult to identify so this is I think
a systems-wide problem you can also
refer to the evidence of Dame Sally
Davis here who says that it's obviously
not just limited to Public Health but
also to numbers of people employed in
health services in general
so just before you go on um if we
if we finish with funding of phe do we
need to consider paragraph 111 of
yes I was going to go on to dealing yes
and that's a convenient moment to do
that now
similar to PHA efficiency drives and
external funding played an important
role in supplementing core budgets
because in 2013 to 14 phe gained an
additional operational income of 180.3
million pounds through research grants
Commercial Services and contract income
and by 2018 to 19 this amount had risen
to
240.4 million pounds that was a
24.2 percent increase on the 2013 to 14
year including inflation
and can we just go a little further down
please
thank you in fact let's let's pause
there
is is it important to recognize
the what's contained within paragraph
111 in looking at the whole picture of
funding both for the HPA and then later
phe I think it's a very important story
it starts already with ph less with the
internal market and the focus of earning
money but under HPA it becomes much more
pronounced so there's a focus within HPA
on winning external grants from funders
like for example the welcome trust or
from the UK government
and also in terms of commercializing
some of the services so spinning out
intellectual property or offering
contractual Services now
in the witness seminars this is
justified by saying it's a moral
imperative to save taxpayer money or via
income generation from public
competencies so to speak
the problem and this is a well-known
problem in international health is that
if you become too reliant on ring fence
short-term funding for specialist
projects it can come at the expense of
core capabilities so you might end up
having a winner so to speak in your
department which is endlessly generating
money and that winner then becomes
favored in terms of resource allocation
by the department and departments within
phe or HPA might get less support for
the ongoing performance of routine
Health functions it also and this is
again from very interesting witness
seminars creates tensions within the
public health organizations between
departments which are seen to be flush
with funding and people who consider
themselves as providing core important
services but might have less time and
resources to devote to winning these
external grants so there is more money
but it's often quite limited it can fall
off cliff edges you can get funding for
a special project but then it just drops
off and it might rights to start
management priorities towards
incentivizing income rather than
necessarily guaranteeing core functions
but if one part of the organization
get to Grant and therefore has
sufficient funds to its work why doesn't
that mean that the money that the
organization would otherwise had to put
into that Department not then move to
core capabilities Department
I think you need to see it in the
context of an overall decline of funding
that is also happening so
redistribution might happen but over
time it creates a distortion of
priorities within the department to
perhaps win funding from certain
elements there's a telling quote from
Sir Mark walpott the director of Public
Health talking to I think one of the HPA
senior Executives where he says I'm a
bit frustrated with HPA we would like to
fund your infectious diseases department
but they never seem to have the capacity
to even apply for the grants in the
first place so I think that would
require more detailed economic analysis
of HP and how they redistributed funds
the anecdotal evidence we have from
senior Executives and also from the
funders themselves suggests that
infectious disease did not perform
perhaps as well as radiation threats
within HPA and then within phe that will
require further research
I'd like to ask you about surge capacity
um because Dame Jenny Harris told the
inquiry that in relation to
microbiological testing of virus samples
and that we're talking about
um hcids such as SARS MERS or SARS cov2
microbiological testing of virus samples
require what she described as a
containment level for laboratory which
is the highest level isn't it and our
only situated in two sites for public
health England colindale and porting
down
and she told the inquiry that if we have
a an hcid or or a pathogen X
that we're uncertain about they need to
be managed in a way which means that
they would almost certainly go to port
and down possibly colindale and and have
to be dealt with initially in those High
containment facilities is that right
um yes all right so so does that mean
that at the time that covid hit there
were only two Laboratories that would
have been able to initially handle the
pathogen
I'm not sure whether this is the total
amount of P4 certified Laboratories in
the UK caught in the airport and down
and colindale have certainly
historically been the places in the UK
where these pathogens were handled and
you see this in the tsar's contingency
plan from 2003 they actually give you
the sample numbers per day that can be
handled in these facilities in the
2003's ass plan
um and um that is clearly that colindale
would be the lead but portendon actually
has a greater capacity for processes
have you discovered through your
research any any concerns as to the
capacity that are Portland down in
colindale provided in terms of the
number of samples that they could
effectively work through at any one time
I'm uncertain about how
the free Labs Etc I can only tell you a
vague estimate in terms of for example
whole genome sequencing capabilities
which played a key role during the early
part of the pandemic and in 2016 the
review of colindale's functions says
that they can do 600 samples per day in
Canada right
can you explain to us Dr kakella how how
the initial
analysis of a pathogen being dealt with
at either port and down or colindale
would then would then flow out to the
other Laboratories
so the sample from colander flowing out
so the sample would not flow out right
it would be typed it would be processed
but the epidemic intelligence that is
gathered would flow out and technically
speaking in form control attempts at the
regional and local level
and at what stage would would phe's
involvement then pass over to to the
other
um local Laboratories
um
so
even with the phls there was a point
when testing would also have been handed
over to the NHS this is part of the
multi-phase plans which the UK has had
since the 1990s where um you divide the
pandemic into specific phases by number
of cases and the community infection for
example and you would then at a certain
point perhaps Handover testing
capabilities this approach becomes much
more pronounced from 2009 onwards with
the rapid deployment of pcrs or
molecular-based testing during the swine
flu pandemic
the HPA
and six established
also had good contacts to NHS virology
Labs which could get this gold standard
diagnostic test and then perform this
test themselves so you need to realize
that there's a big difference in the
time periods that we're talking about
with molecular testing if you have a PCR
machine and you receive the kind of
golden recipe the validated recipe for
testing from colindale you can
technically scale up infinitely if with
with with the Laboratories if if the
Laboratories are using this test and HP
had recognized this capability from the
mid-2000s onwards they did it for swine
flu I think one of the big questions for
module 2 will be how the algorithm for
outsourcing or you know expanding the
testing range was devised for zarzkov
too right
oh the inquiry has heard that there may
be a criticism
laid at the the feat of Public Health
England that that there was
um little engagement with private
testing laboratory facilities in the
Years running up to covid-19 hitting is
that something that is that a criticism
that you have come across and do you
agree with it
I know where the criticism is coming
from when it's in comparison to European
neighbor States like Germany which for
example outsourced they are incentivized
private testing very early on in the
pandemic however I think that in the UK
case
it's a slightly odd criticism because
the UK has a significant sequencing
public capability within the NHS and it
also has significant sequencing
capabilities within the university
sector of which phe was naturally aware
because they were working with all of
these Laboratories prior to the pandemic
so
yes obviously one could have developed
contacts with Private Industry more but
also I think this is not so much a
question of should phe have
automatically gone to the private sector
and have mass scale up with Lighthouse
Labs it's very interesting to see the
NHS capabilities
perhaps not being used as strongly as
some observers would have wanted them to
be used in 2020.
so in terms of of surge capacity given
what you've said about PCR testing and
and the position where Public Health
England was at the time that covid
struck do you consider that there were
any concerns or any valid concerns in
terms of surgery capacity within the
public laboratory system
concerns about surge capacity are voiced
in multiple preparedness exercises when
it comes to the ability to search beyond
the initial hit of one or two hcid cases
in the UK yes and that is a Perpetual
challenge I believe for every emerging
pathogens when you
when when you move from the car Elite
capability of processing and public
health handling towards a broader Health
Systems response right
are you moving to a different topic I am
yes it's been suggested that we break
slightly earlier certainly that's
convenient I'll return it cost you thank
you all right
foreign
we're now going to move to look at the
structural changes in Wales Scotland and
then Northern Ireland
the Welsh Public Health Arrangements you
say diverged significantly from those in
England during the period between 2002
and 2010. the National Public Health
Service for Wales was established in
2003 and then Public Health Wales in
October of 2009 and public health Wales
was tasked with managing Health
protection
epidemiological surveillance and
microbiology services and also Health
Improvement health promotion and child
protection
and is it right that public health Wells
employed the seven local Health Board
directors of Public Health and their
staff of Public Health experts yes I
think so and there was an integrated
network of Public Health Laboratories as
well as communicable disease
surveillance Center in Cardiff and they
were maintained when Public Health Wales
was created yes so just to confirm the
phls in England the reforms abolish the
local level Laboratories Wales decides
to take over that system Wholesale in
2002. so did they carry out Public
Health as well as clinical diagnosis
functions those Laboratories
if they continue to function like the
original pH list yes they did that is
however for further research I think
all right well let's have a look at
107113 which is a report on civil
emergencies in Wales by the Wales audit
office my lady has already seen this
during the evidence of regical Patrick
last week and let's go to page 10 and
have a look at paragraphs 11 sorry 17
and 18. thank you
too many emergency planning groups and
unclear accountabilities add
inefficiency to the already complex
resilience framework the current
resilience structure is similar to the
structure in England with local
resilience forms based on police force
boundaries and with each category one
responder having its own emergency
planning capability we consider that the
current structure is leading to
inefficiencies at a local level
unnecessary complexity and unclear
accountabilities and is an ineffective
framework for resilience in Wales we
also agree with the Simpson review that
there is an urgent need for a
fundamental review of local Authority
emergency planning Services complex
reporting arrangements are leading to
confusion about the roles and
responsibilities of the numerous
emergency planning groups and
organizations this complexity risks
fragmentation of resilience activity
with potential overlaps or gaps in the
arrangements for resilience
now in his evidence to the inquiry Dr
Andrew Goodall said that he believed
that they had addressed some of that
complexity by the time of the pandemic
hitting but he agreed that there had
been many examples of the duplication of
activities happening within the Health
Service and also filtering into the
emergency planning groups is that
something that you recognize I think
this is a challenge across the UK where
you've got the Civil contingencies act
you've got the NHS systems you've got
the public health systems and in an
emergency all of these need to work
together also with local responders so
there is an inherent risk of duplication
and fragmentation and it's it's evidence
I mean in both the tabletop expert
exercises and the reviews of the 2003
can we take that
9575 which is the 2014 communicable
outbreak plan for Wales and have a look
at page two please and what's said here
in the preface in recent years there
have been multiple plans for Wales for
the investigation and control of
communicable disease all these have
contained very similar guidance whilst
it has been recognized that each
individual plan was robust and fit for
purpose the presence of several plans
for use in outbreaks has caused
confusion as to which plan should be
followed therefore at the request of the
Welsh government a multi-agency working
group was convened in 2008 to draw the
plans together into one generic template
and it goes on to say this model plan
the Wales outbreak plan is the result of
that work so just pausing there
a
difficulty or a problem had been
identified in 2008 of there being a
disparate level of plans to follow in
relation to the investigation and
control of communicable diseases this
was the result that was created in 2014.
was this essentially a good idea
I think that the
the identified concern is a correct one
if you if you have too many plans for
too many different diseases people
forget about the plants we've seen that
with the difficulty of re-identifying
the original 2003 sales plan uh from
from the English government
um
the Welsh plan seems to be in line with
other model plans developed for example
for Northern Ireland during this time
where the focus is on generic response
capabilities that can then be mixed and
matched
an improvement then in your view
I think bureaucratically yes I would
perhaps like to make a historical Point
here
um I think the inquiry naturally focuses
on legal documents as the guidelines of
responses if you talk to Public Health
experts they will tell you that an
extremely important component of their
work is the informal ties connecting
them with their with with their
corresponding parts in the health
systems and also in the National
bureaucracies so what I'm trying to say
is that
it's good to see these plans evolving
um I think that the people the experts
within the public health establishment
were much better at abstracting from
this than just following by wrote a plan
system down then then perhaps these
documents lead us to believe and I'm
sure we'll talk about the influenza
framework in a bit but I think this is a
consistent observation in the history of
medicine is that the informal ties the
informal networks regular phone calls
between heads of agencies can do much to
compensate for
um
at first man's administrative
fragmentation or narrow thinking on
paper
all right thank you
in terms of funding the inquiry has
heard from Dr Quentin sanderfer who was
the executive director of Public Health
Services and public health Wales between
2012 and 2020.
and
he told the inquiry that in his view
Public Health Wales was in no way held
back by the funding made available to it
by the Welsh government
um he set out a series of figures and
his evidence was also complemented by
the witness statement of Dr Tracy Cooper
who was public health Wales as chief
executive from June of 2014 and she she
and her witness statement said that the
service Public Health Wells had been
strengthening and transforming its
Workforce model and capacity over the
course of time embracing and developing
an approach to what she described in her
statement as multi multi-disciplinary
practice
and again that that there were little
problems caused by any level or
decreasing level of funding but she did
highlight what she described as a
fragile microbiology service that indeed
needed an input of finance and she
described how that
how that took place over over the course
of of time that that she has been chief
executive of Public Health Wales
do you recognize
that there was a fragility in terms of
the
microbiology laboratory capability and
that that has or was improved
that's very difficult to say because
there are so few comparative reviews of
the UK Health Systems I think the
evidence that's been submitted shows an
interesting discrepancy between funding
levels and perceived robustness again I
think this is subject to more research
all right
Dr sander fertility inquiry that there
was a shortage of microbiologists caused
by a number of factors including the
retirement of senior microbiologists and
difficulties
encountered in public health Wells of of
recruiting more people into post
um
is was that a particular problem
identified and experienced in Wales and
and is is that something that was shared
across the United Kingdom
um and is that something which which you
recognize from your research
I come back to the point I made earlier
about the overall decline of intention
for infectious disease threats from the
70s in my report I cited warning from
1980 that is nearly identical to the
warnings we have in the 2010s about lack
of competence for Infectious Disease
Control and microbiological capabilities
so this recruitment problem that is
experienced by seemingly many Health
Services across the UK is not unique to
the UK it's certainly also prevalent in
North American services so I think this
is part of a broader structural issue in
terms of how educational programs
perhaps incentivize people to specialize
in these areas or not all right as far
as you are aware from your research did
the did the lack of ability to recruit
into these roles and have any any
correlation between a lack of funding or
or was that not the problem I think
that's very difficult to say in
hindsight if you don't have enough
people
um and the funding is challenging um
it's it's difficult to untangle these
these these different factors
did Wales have a problem with their
Laboratories not being fit for purpose
again since this is a high level review
I haven't looked explicitly at the
grading of the Welsh microbiology
Laboratories they did have a robust
spatially distributed infrastructure at
the Handover point of the phls
how much investment was made in
upgrading facilities especially with
regards to these massive technological
transitions that happened between 2000
and 2020 again I think that is something
that needs to be looked at in modem
well one of the documents which you've
been invited to look at is a an
application that public health Wales
submitted for additional funding to the
Welsh government to strengthen its own
specialist Health Protection Services
particularly in microbiology and let's
have a look please at some of the issues
that arise and that are set out during
the course of this paper
thank you this is a paper the proposed
model to strengthen the National Health
Protection Service and it was presented
on the 27th of November of 2018. it was
noted that Investments already made were
positive First Steps but that the model
developed required significant
additional investment and the whole
system approach to strengthening the
National Health Protection Service
required agreement with the health
boards and other trusts it was agreed
that wider engagement with health boards
and trusts should take place before
proposals to the minister were finalized
the chief medical officer and the chief
nursing officer had hosted a workshop on
the 17th of May of 2019 with key
representatives from each Health Board
and Trust to discuss the proposed model
at the workshop there was General
recognition of the challenges described
and general endorsement of the proposals
including Staffing models presented
although the financing of the known gaps
in funding for the proposed model was
not specifically addressed many
delegates commented that they would that
they had been
that they had been to like events in
recent years without any progress being
made
and so a decision was now required
whether to recommend to the minister of
Health that the strengthening of the
National Health Protection Service is a
Welsh government priority and as such
the service could be prioritized for
investment each year up to 22 23. now if
we move down to the summary of the
challenges and just look at the next two
paragraphs
the current microbiology infection
services in Wales are fragile and are
struggling to deliver on a day-to-day
basis the prevention early diagnosis and
Frontline support that professionals and
the public require as a result avoidable
admissions are adding to the pressure on
hospitals and clinicians in many cases
do not have access to the early
diagnosis they require to guide early
and effective treatment which in turn
impacts on inpatient bed days
current microbiology laboratory estate
cannot exploit the opportunity that new
testing Technologies and Robotics can
provide in addition to the lack of
access to Rapid testing there are some
specific Workforce skill capacity
challenges
the current Workforce needs to be
re-skilled and deployed and the service
is unable to recruit to key professional
leadership roles and then if we just
move to paragraph 10 please
Health security has become a greater
Public Health threat
professionals are not confident that
they could at all times provide an
effective response to high consequence
infections as there are points on the
patient care pathway that our single
person dependent
so
it appears that at the time that this
application was made there were serious
concerns about
Workforce capacity about
and the state of the the Laboratories
and and that there was a plea being made
to the Welsh government for further
investment in these regards
and
eyes that that was a problem that had
been caused by the way in which Public
Health Wells was was set up and the
funding situation
I think it's difficult to interpret this
document because there's clearly an
overlap here between NHS diagnostic
services and public health laboratory
services which can be distinct do not
have to be distinct should they be
distinct
that is a political decision at the end
of the day
um and solutions vary according to
countries they can be effective if they
are well resourced well financed and
well staffed what I would like to say
again and this is it's important to
understand the depth of the
technological change that has taken
place here it's one thing to provide a
classic microbiological service with
perhaps limited PCR capabilities whole
genome sequencing requires a raft of
expertise such as bio and bioinformatics
Technologies input from Academia that
may have been easier to draw on in other
parts of the UK I'm thinking of the
Cambridge Oxford London triangle when it
comes to colindale developing
capabilities with Sangha as opposed to
the devolved administrations in other
parts of the UK so I think the
historical Point here is to recognize
that microbiology requires resourcing it
requires staff but that we are now in a
different age of microbiology which
might require different forms of
expertise that aren't equally
distributed across the UK
are you able to comment on the capacity
of Public Health Wales to look to the
English Laboratories the the United
Kingdom wide Laboratories as and when
there might have been need to do so
I think it's an inherent dilemma within
the UK system that colindale is quote
unquote so good with the reference
Services I think for a long time
Laboratories and all devolved
administrations have looked on colindale
to provide expert reference services and
I think that that can sometimes create
capacity issues when perhaps more
specialist microbiological analysis may
be required within the devolved
administrations themselves I know that
the inquiry has looked at hcid treatment
capabilities in these different
countries uh in in the different nations
and um
I think it's it's quite remarkable and
it speaks to the theme of the Giants on
Clay feed article how strong the central
capacity in the south of England has
been built but perhaps how
little consideration has been given to
building sustained capacity in other
parts of the UK
what we see in this application for
funding and the issues that it raises in
terms of capacity
does that give you concern or should
that give the inquiry concern that as as
of January 2020 when covid hit
Public Health whales and the Welsh
system may not have had sufficient
Workforce capacity or laboratory
capacity to deal with an hcid outbreak
I think this document speaks to a
consensus amongst experts who knew their
field and this was a very serious
concern that was raised so absolutely
the inquiry should take this seriously
thank you we can take that down please
moving up to Scotland
by 1945 Scotland already had a
long-standing tradition of independent
Public Health legislation and
Independent Health Systems did it not
and
Scotland decided not to join the
artery service which was set up in 1939
in England which Wales was was also part
of
and I'd like to ask you to what extent
did the Scottish government or public
health bodies in Scotland have control
over testing carried out at the
University Hospitals where their
Laboratories were based
um I think we should not make the
mistake of correlating current efficient
Management systems with the 1940s these
were a high-powered University
professors who part-time did a bit of
microbiology and then also worked in
teaching so the degree of central
control was perhaps more minimal than
now the one key point I think always to
make about the devolved administrations
is that the population density is far
lower and as a consequence if you have
eight people who know each other and
talk to each other regularly it's far
easier to have efficient coordination
and you need less formalized management
control structures in these situations
and Scotland has this is the historical
consensus a long-standing tradition of
this communitarian-based consensus-based
decision-making in these areas
following Devolution did the years
between 1999 and 2004 see the Scottish
government re-emphasize a collaborative
approach to Health Service provision by
abolishing the internal market and that
collaborative approach and the need to
tackle Health inequalities was
emphasized in official planning
documents such as the 999 white paper
towards a healthier Scotland yes all
right and
did initial reforms see the merging of
Scotland's 47 NHS trusts into 28 local
Health Care cooperatives yes
in 2005 was Health protection Scotland
formed to act as a center of epidemic
intelligence capable of rapidly reacting
to Major incidents whilst liaising with
other United Kingdom and European Public
Health hubs yes I think even the names
for UK organizations are clear clue that
you know um how should I say
philosophical
development of Health protection is
evolving along similar lines so we've
got HPA HPS and then now we've got PHS
phe phw so there is a clear and again it
speaks to the
why the academic culture in which these
agencies are based that there's a clear
line of thought that that is leading to
this evolution
microbiological and surveillance
capabilities that had formally been
provided by the Scottish Center for
infection and environmental health
and I think you describing your
reporters rather than creating a
parallel public health system and
employing its own health protection
teams Health protection Scotland worked
as a division within the NHS national
service Scotland organization how did
that differ then from from from the way
in which matters were
so in Wales um in
completely almost completely integrated
organization that uses
ngphs and then later by phw employs
people from the local level to the
National level all in one organization
in one exactly right yes that's my
understanding and in the Scottish case
it builds on these pre-existing
traditions of having rather loose
coordination
via cdsu and that is that that tradition
is is perpetuated with HPS which again
coordinates we aren't speaking about a
huge population we're speaking about a
manageable smaller number of Health
boards so the system you might choose
for that might be different
strategically and in the Scottish case
again because it is smaller people know
each other so lose their epidemic
intelligence
and
doesn't has this Arrangement at all is
because in the 1960s they had outbreaks
that they didn't realize they had
because they had no integrated
epidemiological functions so London told
the Scottish authorities that they had
typhoid and paratyphoid outbreaks and so
this is why this focus on
epidemiological integration is made but
perhaps no streamlining of a coherent
well I shouldn't say coherent but fully
integrated microbiological system so it
worked for Scotland because of the
history which you've just set out but
also the size of the population and the
relationships that existed between those
who were running the services yes and
that is something that is specifically
fostered by repeated Scottish
administrations Scotland is remarkable
for health liaison committees from the
60s and 70s onwards that are designed to
Foster this collaborative spirit
is it right that public health Scotland
became a legal entity in December of
2019 and came into operation in April of
2020. yes the the inquiry has has heard
about those timings and the fact that it
effectively brought together three
Legacy bodies the health protection
Scotland
the information Services Division and
the NHS Health Scotland agency
I'm
in her evidence to the inquiry Dr
Catherine Calderwood has has spoken
about funding of Public Health Scotland
and has said that there was a specific
budget within the overall Healthcare
budget to fund pandemic and emergency
preparedness within NHS Scotland and
specifically Public Health
but she said there's a small proportion
of the overall Healthcare budget is used
to fund Public Health only a small
proportion of that and that there has
long been criticism from those working
in public health in Scotland
um that um in Prevention Services and
resilience groups and towards the
government funding bodies and that their
view is that public health has not
received the funding required for
optimal functioning and outcomes
um and that that in itself has had a
knock-on effect of the ability of those
organizations to properly engage in
pandemic planning is that something that
you recognize from your research
I think it speaks to the overall
problems within the UK system so um
even within the NHS system you can have
public health budgets being raided this
is something that for example in the
case of the UK during the PCT era of the
new labor governments is repeatedly
criticized by the chief medical officer
Liam Donaldson actually I'm quoting here
saying Public Health budgets are being
raided within the NHS to provide other
more short-term Priority Services so
um I think the wider Point here is to
say that regardless which organizational
structure you choose to embed your
public health system in and you need to
protect the core budgets because
clinical colleagues can take resources
from public health and in the case of
the local authorities if you don't fund
sufficient Public Health Services they
will also regardless of efficiency be
unable to deliver core functions
over this course of time between
2002 up until the onset of covid
does your research tell you that there
were as as we've just discussed in terms
of Wales any Workforce or or laboratory
difficulties
um or or problems um in within Scotland
um not that I know of but that is a
factor of I think the six weeks that I
had to research the reports so if I had
more time perhaps I would be able to
find something all right
um I want to move now to
look at Northern Ireland and the
evolution of health services in Northern
Ireland which in Broad terms are
paralleled by what was happening
um elsewhere in the United Kingdom
um in in 1953 there was uh the creation
of Northern Ireland Central Public
Health Laboratories
and um that Network expanded
and then following the passage of the
1999 Northern Ireland act did Northern
Ireland
um regain its competences for
structuring its health and public health
services are on its own I believe so yes
all right
is there a significant Divergence from
Wales and Scotland in Northern Ireland
in terms of how the surveillance
functions of the Laboratories were set
up
Northern Ireland is is very interesting
because in 1999 the decision is made to
um Outsource or to contract the phls and
then later the HPA to provide the
epidemiological functions of Northern
Ireland so rather than directly creating
its own completely homogeneous Public
Health System the the key epidemic
intelligence point is actually provided
by the phls and the phls representative
is accountable
both to the northern Irish government
and the CMO but also to the phls so this
is a very unique contractual engagement
maybe the result of the smaller
population size of Northern Ireland
during this time I haven't found any
detailed justification of why this
decision was made to Outsource
rather than build the capacity
within Northern Ireland
there were a number of Health and Social
Services boards created and also local
Health and Social trusts which were in
charge of the Laboratories is that right
yes
um these these trusts however and these
Arrangements predated
um the the Good Friday agreements yes
did they carry on post the the good
Fighters yes
and
is that still the position in terms of
the the local trusts running the
microbiological services
um no so in 2009 Northern Ireland
undergoes significant reforms both for
the public health system but also for
its wider Health and Social care system
so you've now got a completely
integrated and I hope I'm getting my my
terminology right Health and Social care
board
which commissioned services from Health
and Social care trusts right the report
contains the correct terminology here
but essentially what you have is a
completely now integrated system of
commissioning from trusts and also from
local Health authorities
of microbiology services but the trusts
run most of the major microbiology Labs
including the central one in Belfast
which is run I think by the East Belfast
trust but the the the correct detail is
in the report all right
you tell us in the report that there was
a review of Northern Ireland's Public
Health functions in 2004.
and that that review
um expressed concern about an
over-reliance on English services and
suggested replacing the hpa's cdsc
Northern Ireland with a new Regional
Northern Irish Health protection body
and is that what happened that is what
eventually happened in the case of
Northern Ireland obviously the
overarching political context is very
important to understand there were
repeated breakdowns of power sharing and
so
multiple reviews expressed slightly
varying concerns and the actual time
windows for political action
um were around 2009 for many of these
reforms that then eventually took place
to 2015 when the then Minister for
health Simon Hamilton announced that in
response to recommendation one of the
right time the right place report by
psyllium Donaldson that he would appoint
an expert clinically LED panel to
consider and Lead an informed debate on
the best configuration of Health and
Social care services in Northern Ireland
and that board was led by Professor
Rafael bengoer and a name that was
mentioned during the evidence of Robin
Swann to my lady on Friday
now the resultant bengoer report covered
the issues of inequalities
the Aging population
primary care and Hospital services and
Workforce as well and the main
recommendation of the report was that
there should be a triple aim within
Health and Social care in Northern
Ireland to improve patient experience to
improve health the health puppy of the
population and to provide a better value
in terms of funding and output
now
that report
um in 2015
was then taken forward because in 2016
there was a further review
um that Drew up on the bengala report of
the Northern Ireland Health System
called systems not structures chain
2017 acting
which followed on from the committee and
then the report which was
um which was provided in in 2016 2017.
health and well-being plan is that right
yes and what
um
there were problems with power
so I believe
although the report had been
presented in
2016-2017 we know that there was then a
breakdown of the power sharing agreement
between 2017 and 2020. so are you able
to to in any way accurately predict
which part of the report were brought
into force and whether the aims were in
fact ever achieved
again that's very difficult to say
because
um even with the best will of an
Administration given the breakdown of
pausing given the uncertainties of
planning and I think you've also got
another expert report on this
um that uh it's any any ambitious reform
could not have been completely
implemented given these circumstances
um but again I I guess I wave my my
right here as a historian to say that I
focus more on the past and and not on
the foreign implementation
well having looked at the
structure of public services and their
history in in all four nations I want to
turn now to to talk about
what you as a historian are able to
comment upon in terms of
and focus first of all on what you
describe
being the first major test
occurred in 2003
issued
unfortunately the UK experienced a small
number of probable cases and no
fatalities before the World Health
Organization announced that human to
human transmission had been broken in
Late July of 2003.
but you do record that between March and
July of that year the public health
agency dealt with
368 reports of suspected cases of which
nine were classified as
that the outbreak nonetheless revealed
the significant strains that even a
comparatively small outbreak could place
on the UK's Public Health Systems
can you expand upon that please and why
you say that despite there being a
relatively minor outbreak and only one
confirmed case that that led to obvious
strains
the volume of testing that was
you have to remember that in the case of
Zars HPA was just in the process of
being set up yes so it's infancy Yes
actually it's created right in the
middle of the pandemic wave so that
might explain some of this however later
assessments do reveal that the new pcts
may have had too little PPE
oh and this is an important thing
um revered that there was a problem with
regards to local access to epidemic
intelligence that was relevant to the
local level what what were those
problems the problems were that the
local level was reporting suspected
clinical diagnosis of SARS up to HPA but
there was a problem of communicating
this down effectively via the regional
health protection teams to
um to the relevant clinical authorities
within the NHS we have to remember that
SARS at this time was primarily a big
challenge in nosocomial so in in
hospital settings
and that pcts and authorities within the
NHS and also the local Authority level
had a big problem with the fact that
they did not have all of the information
at their hands that they might have had
earlier the second thing is obviously to
remember that people barely knew the new
structures of HPA at this time so in
testimonies of the time the
microbiologists recall that spent a lot
of time just phoning Laboratories that
had previously been phls to send samples
and Report samples up to the HPA for
example
so was there a lack of clarity in terms
of which Laboratories were performing
which
assessments and and
um and which roles yes that is one of
the problems that can however obviously
be explained by the structural flux
within which the system was the most
Salient points I think was lack of
access to relevant information another
point that was identified was lack also
of local epidemiological competence to
act on this information now that HPA was
more
for the covet 2 outbreak
the lack of PPE stored within Primary
Care trusts and the final point that one
later review revealed was a fear that
given the small number of Staff working
at HPA there was a danger of burnout of
Key Personnel during prolonged surges
well I just want to to take a look at
paragraph 83 of your report which is at
page 58 because you produce a quote from
the pH ls's former head of virology
Philip Mortimer
and we can see that towards the bottom
of the paragraph let's just pick it up
please three lines up from the bottom
and if we couldn't thank you if we can
read through what you say here about
Philip mortemer's warning writing in
2003 the pH ls's former head of virology
Philip Mortimer warned that
over-reliance on centralized epidemic
intelligence in the absence of
sufficient local capacity for testing
contact tracing and isolation beds could
prove costly during future pandemics
what was needed was sustained investment
and let's look at the quote itself
please he says it should not be assumed
that a recurrence of SARS is therefore
unlikely or that a further outbreak
would be controllable
if there are weaknesses or deficiencies
it should not be thought that they can
or should be repaired by quick fixes
each time an acute threat materializes
such expenditures fail to build the
infrastructure needed to maintain a
comprehensive capacity for rapid and
technologically appropriate response to
new pathogens and over time they distort
facilities and so hinder the effective
management of the laboratory
in your
article Giants on Clay feet you describe
what Philip Mortimer is expressing here
as being prescient because of what we
now know went on to to happen with covet
19.
um
what notice was was taken of these sorts
of issues not necessarily from Mr
Mortimer himself but from what you have
seen the concerns that you have said
were expressed coming out of the SARS
outbreak
did it lead to any action
um within any of the areas which which
about which concern is being expressed
so the UK does
um develop Azar's plan that is published
in or not officially published not
publicly published in late 2003
following the experience of the zaas
pandemic and that plan warns that there
may be Community transmission of a
recurrence of zarzkov 1 which is a
distinct virus from zarzkopf Tool
the plan has numerous recognition
recommendations for how Authority should
deal with it to my knowledge I have not
seen any other plan that is building
capacity to address the the gaps
identified in this plan
um I should say that mortimer's warnings
here are not isolated these are warnings
that surface from other people in the
health system too and can I just ask the
health system within the United Kingdom
all worldwide
in the United Kingdom primarily there
are however also concerns in other
Western Health Systems raised about the
ability to provide sufficient surge
capacity should an outbreak like SARS
prove more sustains there's also
initially a recognition that if you want
to control us you need to act very fast
and take it very hard when it comes to
for example
improving infection control procedures
within hospitals and resorting to things
such as school closures the 2003 plan
actually mentions Hospitality sector
closures in response to it so these are
significant learnings in many ways that
are taken here will come to 2009 with
the swine flu pandemic yes which is a
difference obviously theoretical or no
real risk all right but but so
in the way in which we see here not
but also
I believe
the frisaster report is Peter hobby so
that is somebody obviously who is quite
senior within the yes and has has
assisted the inquiry
before we move to to look at
what we learned from the 2009 swine flu
outbreak I just want to to remind
ourselves
um that in terms of the chronology in
2007 between SARS and Swine Flu there
was exercise winter Willow which was a
large-scale pandemic tabletop exercise
of 5 000
as well as the need to strengthen
linkages between established local and
Regional resilience structures and their
equivalence within the NHS so so an
indication then that there needed to be
links strengthened within the the
various four nations and then to the
2009 swine flu pandemic you say in your
report that the official reviews painted
an overall positive picture of the
United Kingdom response and that Praises
were centered around Advanced
procurement orders the rapid development
of the PCR diagnostic test by colindale
and various responses um on the ground
and this inquiry has heard much about
the subsequent review that was
commissioned and
um which in relation to which Dane
Deidre Hein produced her report the
following year
now in in the main the report
Dr kirkell you point to what you
describe as difficulties issues that
were raised by independent observers by
historians I and by public workers in
the field
do you suggest that
the
sentiments and
um and and decisions expressed by Dame
Deidre Hein being at odds with the um
the expressions of concern that you have
found could be explained by the people
and the positions of those people who
were asked to provide information for
the report
I think there is a clear misalignment
despite this being a very good report
overall of the swine flu pandemic of
what people at the national level say
about the UK response as opposed to
Independent research which was conducted
at the cold front of the pandemic during
the pandemic what what are those
differences key differences in the
response are that emerge as a result of
of detailed interviews of Frontline
workers in 2009 are that there was much
more pronounced misalignment and
confusion about responsibilities at the
local level than appears in the report
the report also says that there were
confusions and that in future again
integration needs to be strengthened but
what especially Professor Virginia
Barrage at the London School of hygiene
and tropical medicine conducted during
this time shows that there were
significant other tensions about
responsibilities between NHS HPA and
also confusion about what local
resilience fora were supposed to perform
you know um so there was misalignment
and there was confusion about roles that
is something that emerges
quite clearly from these statements
um I think another
thing that is mentioned that is
interesting for the expert advice system
was that figures within HPA who were
interviewed by Professor barrage the
reports could never be published the
publication was according to Professor
Barrack stopped also noted that there it
was difficult sometimes for HPA in wider
expert meetings such as Sage to assert
itself because they were often
presenting a corporate view of expertise
as opposed to more independent
statements by other Sage members and
finally HPA also perceived it to be
difficult and this is something that
emerges also in the hind review
to sometimes reconcile its own forecasts
of pandemic severity with reasonable
worst case scenarios that were
frequently mobilized by the CMO of the
time there and Donaldson in warnings to
the press for example all right
you conclude in your report that whilst
the 2009 epidemic ultimately proved less
severe than feared and showcased the
startling potential of molecular
Diagnostics and a vaccine design it also
revealed that well-known problems of
local and National coordination and
resourcing had not been resolved and to
that from what you have just told us you
would add a a lack of clarity in terms
of the roles that people were expected
to fill during the course of the
outbreak and in and in order to react to
it I think that's a consistent feature
yes all right
um just one one thing I would like to
add though is is this was not just
something that was unique to swine flu
this was also highlighted by further
reviews of the Public Health Systems so
at the time even before swine flu so in
2007 the European Centers for Disease
Control and again you will find the
references and in in the report and um I
believe also um
parliamentary committees were interested
in these issues and and highlighted the
need to look for that local local
coordination
following on from the Hein review the
inquiry has heard much about the 2011
United Kingdom pandemic influenza
strategy with its learnings and emphasis
on individual Behavior
and one of the criticisms that my lady
has heard it is about the comparative
lack of consideration of non-medical
countermeasures and that perhaps more
should have been
um more should have been said in this
strategy about the aspects of social
distancing or school closures or even
lockdown which we know does not appear
within the strategy
but but has your your work Dr kirkella
and
shown that in fact some of those
non-medical countermeasures as you
described them had been raised in
previous
papers and the reaction to the 2003 SARS
outbreak and the 2009 swine flu outbreak
and that they were very much on the
radar even though they might not have
been considered and certainly not
considered in detail within the strategy
and the non-medical interventions are
core part of pandemic planning from the
1990s onwards it's a core part of the
1997 UK multi-phase influenza plan in
2003 in the case of Zars with the plan
that is released we have many of the
interventions that are later rolled out
during the kovitz 2 outbreak happening
so from and we also during swine for we
have school closures we have border
controls we have with ebola later on to
travel restrictions or travel cautions
we have Hospitality sectors being
concerned what is however new obviously
in
2019-2020 with with covid-19 is the
scale of lockdowns the scale of societal
closure that is considered I don't think
that that was conceived of in the
initial influenza plans where the
traditional emphasis of government has
always been on business continuity so
minimizing disruption to trade
minimizing also disruption to the econ I
mean that's uh
um that's that's a that's a core part of
pandemic planning essentially from the
late 1970s onwards
I I also want to ask you about a a
another developing area of consideration
in terms of pandemic planning and it
relates to Behavioral Science
you say that within the United Kingdom
the status of both epidemiological
modeling and behavioral scientists in
pandemic responses and in pandemic
planning has received what you describe
as a significant upgrade during the
mid-20 to 2000s and and ongoing from
there
and I I'd like to look please at a
report
which is called the Mind space report
it's at
207-450 by the cabinet office and
Institute for government which
underlined the advantages of Lo of using
what they describe as low-cost
low-paying ways of tackling problems
um and let's look please at
page four
this was a review that was prompted by
Sir Gus O'Donnell and we can see his
signature there at the bottom together
with some Michael bickard and if we read
into
um what what the report was really set
up to achieve influencing people's
behavior is nothing new to government
which has often used tools such as
legislation regulation or taxation to
achieve desired policy outcomes but many
of the biggest policy challenges we are
now facing such as the increase in
people with chronic health conditions
will only be resolved if we are
successful in persuading people to
change their behavior their Lifestyles
or their existing habits fortunately
over the last decade our understanding
of influences on Behavior has increased
significantly and this points the way to
new approaches and new Solutions so
whilst behavioral theory has already
been deployed to good effect in some
areas it has much greater potential to
help us to realize that potential we
have to build our capacity and ensure
that we have a sophisticated
understanding of what does influence
behavior this report is an important
step in that direction because it shows
how behavioral Theory could help achieve
better outcomes for Citizens either by
complementing or established policy
tools or by suggesting more Innovative
interventions in doing so it draws upon
on the most recent academic evidence as
well as exploring the wide range of
existing good work in applying
behavioral Theory across the public
sector and finally it shows how these
insights could be put to practical use
so this report tackles complex issues on
which there are a wide-ranging public
views we hope it will stimulate debate
amongst policy makers and stakeholders
and help us bring our capability to use
Behavior theory in an appropriate and
effective way
thank you we can take that down please
now You observe in your report uh Dr
kakella that
citing this this mind uh space report
that the authors of the 2011 strategy
hoped that there would be
um
more of a a consideration of voluntary
responsible behavior that effectively
Behavioral Science was being
identified not only by those involved in
in drafting the strategy but also as we
can see those who are looking more
widely at the the health of the United
Kingdom and that it was becoming an
important consideration in
planning
or attempting to plan as as to how
um best to tackle something like a
pandemic when it was next going to hit
is that reflected in your knowledge and
and research of what was going on about
this time so we're now talking 10 years
or so before the pandemic hit
there's a marked increase in interest
and behavioral Theory from around 2000
onwards this is not just in the UK this
is also the who level where there's a
consistent focus on non-medical
interventions but also focusing on
vaccine uptake in the population now
it's it's very interesting historical
coincidence that this new emphasis that
is placed on behaviorist science which
primarily uses social cues to nudge
people in the right direction there's
also nudge unit founded in the cabinet
office during this time it coincides
with the election of a government which
emphasizes individual responsibility and
Market efficient responses Behavioral
Science at this time is closely
integrated with Market psychology
and um the and I'll slow down um
and uh it's it's a core part also of the
hind review of 2009 that more use could
be made of it and the UK's advice Crimea
they start taking up on this from around
25 onwards and start using behavioral
scientists to draft for example business
as usual messages for the UK government
so to say continue to go to work the
situation is under control what is
interesting what is missing from the
behavioral scientific advice that is
response or representation from social
sciences disciplines which are more
structural so which try and understand
the structural determinants of behavior
versus individual psychological
determinants of behavior and obviously
from 2015 onwards a large part of the
research on social priming that
underlies these hopes for behaviorist
interventions at the scientific level
experience is a crisis the so-called
replication crisis where some of the
assumptions about effects that can be
scaled up to a population size
are not replicable in repeat experiments
so the scientific advice and the state
of science changes quite significantly
during this time right
does that mean that in your opinion
um enough emphasis was placed upon a bit
Behavioral Science in pandemic planning
and in what we're going to look at
briefly now in the exercises that were
performed
I think clearly no because the emphasis
here is on
um assumptions of the behavior in a
universal individual with not enough
regard to cultural and structurally
determined aspects of behavior so how
would ethnic minorities respond to
Public Health interventions sorry I I
want to bring you one please to to look
at in particular the
um the results from exercise sickness
which about which my lady has has heard
much during the course of this inquiry
and just to set it into context as we
know you've already mentioned the Ebola
outbreak which we know about then there
was the exercise Alice exercise dealing
with a MERS outbreak in 2016 and other
such exercises culminating in the the
large exercise of cygnus which my lady
has heard much about and the report
thought which which came out of that
exercise and in in your consideration of
the report you tell us that the exercise
revealed significant pandemic
vulnerabilities and that the final
report warned that there is no overview
of pandemic response plans and
procedures and that the health systems
restructuring across all devolved
administrations meant that key
organizations referred to in in plans
and the 2011 strategy no longer existed
but it's the it's the issue that you
picked up about
vulnerabilities and and that in
conjunction with Behavioral Science that
I'm going to suggest
um might have been missing and what do
you say about
the fact that vulnerabilities
were capable of being identified during
the course of that exercise and flowing
from it from 2016 but may not have found
their way into that the pandemic plans
and how that sits with what you've just
described as a lack of consideration of
Behavioral Science
so there are multiple things to unpack
it with vulnerabilities right there are
Health vulnerabilities
the inquiry from other experts I think
that what's quite remarkable about the
tabletop exercises is that they assume
uh homogeneity of the UK population
which is being managed in response to an
exercise there are always calls for more
research on how populations would
respond to triage to mass burials Etc
but there's very little remarkably
little consideration given to the fact
that the UK has become a substantially
more diverse population in this time
that people with different cultural
backgrounds different experiences will
have different responses and
expectations of what health services
deliver now this is not in the report
this is um this is something that
however should be looked into more with
ebola anthropologists proved crucial in
optimizing responses in response to
burial practices but it seems that the
UK was good at employing anthropologists
for foreign responses it would have been
good to see more ethno ethnographic and
sociological studies of mixed responses
within the UK population itself to
restrictions Mass mandates things like
that
thank you so
drawing those threads together
the potential to have more consideration
to Behavioral Science the the potential
to have more consideration to
various vulnerabilities including Health
inequalities in pandemic planning
and apparently I'm sorry if I may just
interrupt or it's not just the
behavioral sciences it's actually the
social sciences so that we have an
acknowledgment of structural variation
within the UK population feeding into
plants which are supposed to protect the
health of this population all right
thank you for that and if we look at
paragraph 139 of your report we can see
your conclusions
um in this respect and your comments on
the tabletop exercises and the the
results of those exercises so it's page
90 paragraph 139 in your report
urge during
warnings about the same vulnerabilities
also underlined the difficulties UK
planners faced in moving from tabletop
exercises and influencer plans to
creating and sustaining the real
physical infrastructures stuffing levels
and Regulatory alignment necessary for
an effective pandemic response although
pandemic preparedness remained a
frequently voiced concern actual UK
infection control capacity building
between 2010 and 2019 was undermined by
budget cuts regulatory
heterogeneity can you explain to us what
that is please
um multiple not homogeneous regulatory
systems so different diverse yes thank
you repeated Health Service shake-ups
Workforce shortages and rapidly
expanding Public Health remits following
the 2016 brexit referendum there was
also concern about reduced European
coordination and a loss of British
influence on European Public Health
bodies
thank you
we can take that down
so
all of the clues were there
some of them had been picked up and had
formed part of the pandemic planning
but there were warnings and alerts which
which which hadn't been given perhaps as
much emphasis as they might
and when one takes into account the the
issues which you've also set out in
terms of funding and Workforce capacity
um how do you say that that the planning
and the issues that were affecting the
United Kingdom in the run-up to covid-19
hitting created a difficulty
so I think what we see in this period
obviously the warnings we see the
tabletop exercises but we don't see a
political consistent political ownership
of the issues that are raised
um pandemic repentance is frequently
voiced in public
um there are lots of Hollywood movies in
popular culture it also has a high has a
high place but at the political level
there doesn't seem to be a consistent
driver in terms of improvement of the
capabilities and this is caused by I
would say budget pressures that are
imposed the need for efficiency to
manage reductions and finally and you
have heard multiple Witnesses testify to
this preparations for the real projected
threat of the exit from the EU perhaps
overshadowing resilience planning
especially in the last three years
before the pandemic
you also refer in in your conclusion
there to the the Stark difference
between
considering an issue during a tabletop
exercise and really being prepared for
the reality when it hits
do you think that the exercises that
about which this inquiry has heard
um are effective are worthwhile could be
improved or is that always going to be a
Chasm between thinking about something
within the the clinical confines of a of
a meeting room and the reality when it
hits
I think the truth of that is
self-evident the exercises are important
they get people into contact who need to
know each other however similar to the
the proverb about battle plans the first
thing that goes out of the window within
an hour is the battle plan that that
situation you need to have the
resilience and the resources to Pivot
and adapt and remember statements from
Mike Ryan from The Who during the first
months of the pandemic saying that you
just need to um you
failure is okay you continue you just
need to continue adapting and for that
you need to have the resources and the
resilience in place and you need to have
the trust and the knowledge about who's
responsible for what between key actors
before coming to to your conclusions as
you set them out in the report just
before you do can I ask Rafi how long I
think I'll be five minutes more my lady
because then Mr Larry's got some
questions all right well
um I'm happy to break now if my lady
would prefer
I prom I think probably
um our Brave's not unless unless it
causes you any problems if we I would
just
final point please about if I may I know
whether we break now oh yes well yes of
course you could be back this afternoon
oh yeah I can yeah I can do that okay we
shall return at uh ten to two please
whole rice
[Applause]
foreign
thank you
it's black off thank you my lady Dr
kirkella before we look at the
conclusions that you draw in your report
I'd just like to ask you about the
global Health security index about which
the inquiry has already heard
and
the United Kingdom's ranking in the
category rapid response and mitigation
of the spread of an epidemic
I'm Professor Mark woolhouse has told
the inquiry that in scoring considerably
higher than any other Nation with the US
coming in second in this category and
there is a danger of a risk of
complacency that the government could
reasonably claim that it was well
prepared for a pandemic citing that
independent evaluation do you agree with
that concern I think there's a there's a
risk involved there okay but secondly
he went on to say
to sensible
proved a very poor indicator of outcomes
in the face of an actual pandemic not
only for the UK and the us but for other
countries as well and perhaps that
indicates that we should not confuse
preparedness as defined by the index
with vulnerability and that the global
Health Community needs to reevaluate the
relationship between the two
he totally inquired this until that is
done it will be difficult for any
government to make an objective
assessment of either do you agree with
that I think that's true yes
further in his evidence
Professor woolhouse told the inquiry
last week that the designer of the
indices defended them on the grounds
that they weren't intended to be
predictive
um and he then asked rhetorically well
if they weren't then what were they for
um taking all of that into account do
you think that these types of
international reviews are helpful or do
they create the Trap of complacency and
fail to have any or any sufficient
regard to vulnerabilities so I read the
same article that that Professor
woolhouse read and I had the same
thought with regards to the conclusion
that the office Drew there so
I think that International comparisons
actually are incredibly important for
public health preparedness the question
is what kind of comparisons we have with
the global Health security index it was
a very specific form of evaluation that
over emphasized technological
preparedness the capability to sequence
rapidly respond to outbreaks but didn't
accurately take into account the overall
Baseline capacities of Health Systems
and Public Health Systems in these
countries there's also an issue here at
the international level with experts
being drawn primarily from English and
American settings going to the same
Public Health Schools and then perhaps
evaluating quite a technologically
according to quite a technologically
based Paradigm Health Systems
performance so what you see with the
with the global Health security index
was a simplification of what
preparedness consists of and it's very
much in keeping with this line of
thought that I've described emerging
from the 1990s onwards this focus on
Upstream top heavy epidemic intelligence
but it it leaves out of the equation
what happens when these centers of
excellence are overwhelmed when they
fail
so that was to reduced nonetheless
within the EU when the UK was still a
member you had regular ecdc ratings of
preparedness and regular talking through
of Public Health Systems performance
those were useful they were taken on
board by the UK government some of the
some of the ratings there so
International comparisons matter but we
shouldn't be overly focused that they
actually paint a completely accurate
picture
now to your conclusions you say in your
report that the past offers no simple
and Timeless solutions for the future of
Public Health across the United Kingdom
but
having analyzed eight Decades of
evolving infection control
you see that there are four Central
challenges going forwards uh
first
declining attention second
administrative misalignment third
emergency priorities and fourth what you
describe as selective memory
so just dealing with each of those
individually please
first of all declining attention
is there a perceived problem that that
you have identified and you can now
acknowledge as a problem going forward
that
most UK citizens don't perceive
infectious disease as a significant
threat to life
that is true I and why is that a problem
it's multifaceted most UK citizens
within their family have lived memories
of multiple pandemics including here by
the way also the HIV aids pandemic which
spread in the 1980s and yet over the
years we have seen a consistent decline
of societal attention for infectious
disease threats
there are multiple
connected reasons for this the overall
reason is obviously that the primary
cause of death in this country has
increasingly shifted towards
non-communicable diseases
parallel with this however is a problem
of investment and protecting the
infrastructures that have allowed this
decline to take place in the first place
so the reason my report goes back to the
1930s is to Showcase how these Baseline
infrastructures function they run quite
smoothly most of the time when it comes
to decreasing overall disease pressures
on society and ironically by by
functioning so smoothly attention for
their maintenance declines
and this we can see with investment
levels when it comes to protecting core
capabilities such as local public health
Laboratories local public health
specialties
Etc
there's also interlinked with this
obviously the other issue of advocacy
so when we go again back to the
beginning of this period Public Health
was very much focused on Infectious
Disease Control but what we see now with
public health is a very broad
multidisciplinary family of approaches
that focus on health Improvement
prevention
Etc and Infectious Disease Control this
car original capability is no longer
necessarily at the Forefront of this
thinking we see it with the recruitment
but we also see it with problems of
advocacy within the Public Health
Community when it comes to protecting
and prioritizing Infectious Disease
Control and to layer on to that the
final thing if we then broaden the remit
of the public health agencies that we
task with protecting Public Health more
and more and more to cover more aspects
we will inevitably find that persistent
lobbying for the protection of these
Baseline infrastructures will be drowned
out by other issues over time so
um it's it's a multi it's a staggered
problem in many ways but what needs to
be done is to increase a permanent
advocacy for the maintenance of Baseline
capabilities that protect you when
technology isn't available to curb and
outbreak
and by doing that visibility will be
maintained and and possibly even
increased
ideally yes but we shouldn't expect that
societal memories of covid-19 remain
stable is three indicates otherwise
history indicates that forgetfulness was
set in and that alternative priorities
will come so what you need is a
persistent independent
lobbying and protection of resources
within government and also within the
profession
what about
Central challenge that
you gribe as administrative misalignment
um
one of the leading historians of
medicine always describes Global Health
as essentially local nothing at the
global level really matters if it can't
be put into action locally effectively
so Public Health continuously has a
challenge of aligning Health Systems
responses with public health
surveillance and other local responses
and integrating it nationally into a
complete holistic picture and
intelligence-led approach to Public
Health and what we've seen in the UK
already before the evolution but
accelerating after the evolution is an
increasing I I like the word diverse set
of of administrative
um
structures at the local level and at the
national levels in the devolved
administrations This is complicated by
the fact in my opinion that UK HSA is de
facto in English Public Health
Administration yet has obviously uk-wide
remits other countries I'm German for
example have a federal system that is
fully Federal where you have an
Administration that then navigates
between individual state-led Public
Health Systems but in the UK this this
results in the the fact that we have a
kind of hybrid system
results in very difficult alignment
processes and we see the evidence of
this and the tabletop exercises and also
in this very telling Department of
Health review from 2017 where it said
that people within Public Health England
didn't necessarily know who even to call
or when to call devolved administrations
and if I'd looked in the devolved
administrations I'm sure I might have
found similar references with regards to
who's responsible for what's within
colander
so ensuring a clarity
as to role and responsibility would
assist in terms of what you describe as
administrative misalignment there's no
optimal solution
all of the devolved administrations have
experimented with different systems we
also see historically different systems
in the UK but I think what would help
would be to avoid reformism So to avoid
changing everything up every 10 years
and changing the name of structures and
organizations which is interesting
it because it seems to happen after
crisis which seems to draw artificial
lines after things so
there is a clear need to either
stabilize arrangements and make them
work better or to have a more
participant-led discussion about how to
structure UK wide
things going forward I draw here on the
selective memory because at the moment
most of the memories that are always
drawn on our English memories when it
comes to restructuring Public Health
Systems so it needs to be in my opinion
a more representative a more diverse
process that is not just LED from
Westminster but but has more active
involvement of the developed
administrations well drawing upon your
movement into the selected memory
challenge
as well as what you've just told the
inquiry in terms of the devolved
administrations and and the UK wide
memory needing to be captured
is it also your view that there needs to
be a proper representative
um amount of memory coming from
different layers of Public Health
um memory capture has been a formal part
of pandemic planning since the 1990s and
yet while reading these enormous amounts
of reports as a historian since this
time I've been repeatedly struck at how
narrow some of the capturing has been
often enough it's National institutions
capturing memories that focus on
National responsibilities that then
results in new organizations being
created or responsibility shifted around
between different Ministries but rarely
have I seen memory capture exercises
that actually have ample evidence from
the local level and I think this is
something that relates to the key
identified repeated weaknesses in the UK
pandemic preparedness that that comes
out of the reports where local
perspectives and local alignment seems
to be one of the most sticky issues when
it comes to preparedness so ensuring a
representative
participatory form of memory capture
that draws on the dph the infection
control nurses the specialists at the
local level seems absolutely Central and
to add to this
capturing in great detail the
experiences of the devolved
administrations and I think in the
inquiry this has come out repeatedly
capturing data that is comparable across
evolved administrations is absolutely
key to ensuring a more robust base of
evidence moving forward
and your final challenge going forward
you describe as emergency priorities how
how can we best prepare ourselves for
for what might come next in terms of our
emergency priorities
I think there's a philosophical dilemma
here because if you prepare for one
emergency in a range of multiple
emergencies
devoting all of your resources towards
these these specific scenarios might
actually end up weakening your core
Baseline capacity so what we see from
the 1990s onwards is a shift towards
this top heavy Upstream mode of an
epidemic intelligence and preparedness
this is not limited to the UK it's also
in other countries
um
amidst the decline of the bread and
butter Public Health capacity that you
need when the center fails and this is I
think a Core theme especially in the
case of England that is quite prominent
from around 2000 onwards and we see we
started playing out with covid-19 but we
saw the warnings earlier about the
repeated capacity problems and the fact
that um Global reviews of the UK systems
focus on these centers of excellence but
perhaps might neglect the the um the
Baseline Hinterland capacity
um of preparedness that I refer to in
the Giants and clear feet article yes
and finally groupthink the inquiry has
heard varying views on this and whether
or not it's existed and caused any
difficulty in some of the scientific
organizations and groups that were
either permanently set up or or stood up
for an incident such as as coven 19.
as a historian what is your view of of
group thinking have you seen it present
in in some of the groups that you've
looked into
I think at the scientific level there is
no evidence whatsoever of groupthink
it's such a diverse planning landscape
and we see it with the who in 2018
putting disease X formally onto pandemic
planning Landscapes we see it with the
planning for all kinds of high
consequence infectious diseases we see
it with the fact that the UK had a
tsar's plan it had a MERS plan there was
planning across multiple pathogens
the fact that it still remained an
influencer based framework I agree here
with Jenny Harris assessment is that
influenza was the most realistic disease
to plan for why was that we have
the most robust historical data of
pandemics based on influenza and they
occur regularly it's not just 1918. the
UK had a pandemic in the 1950s in the
1960s there was a major scale in the
1970s another major scale in the 1990s
and a major scare of an actual pandemic
in the 2009 so it's realistic to see
influenza as the most likely respiratory
pathogen that can occur and that can
spread there were obviously failures to
update the plan for New knowledge
emerging around asymptomatic
transmission and aerosolized
transmission
but that doesn't mean that this amounts
to group thing and I come back to the
point I made early in my hearing that a
legal document is not necessarily
representative of a very diverse
ecosystem of thinking about pandemics
and again we only need to look to
popular culture where actually there's a
huge amount of pandemic scenarios
already embedded with board games with
multiple pathogens and all of these
things around so my point here is
um
influenza is a realistic framework to
base pandemic planning around it's there
regularly
moving forward it might be useful to
perhaps have more generic names and
prepare more generically for Airborne
pathogens but I don't subscribe
historically to the argument that
group think delayed preparedness
in 2019 December we have the first phase
one clinical trial of immerse
coronavirus vaccine starting in Oxford
and then in Saudi Arabia this is
physical evidence that group think was
not present the UK was prepared for
multiple High consequence infectious
diseases with pandemic potential
for going forwards there needs to be a
flex doesn't there there needs to be a
an ability to adapt whatever
preparedness
follows from from from this inquiry and
and in the days forwards there has to be
an element of adaptability yes I mean
while writing the report I asked myself
the one counterfactual question would
the UK have performed better had it been
a classic influencer pandemic that hit
the country in 2020
and I think there were serious doubts
about the ability to handle that the PPE
levels had fallen precariously low the
resourcing at the local level was not
there the communication Pathways had not
been addressed Etc so yes we dealt with
covid-19 as a novel pathogen
would the UK have performed so much
better had it been a classic still the
novel influenza strain
um I have my doubts
thank you very much Dr kirkeller my lady
you've provisionally provided permission
for
um covid buried families for justice
Northern Ireland to ask questions on a
topic May that now be done
it's lovely
[Applause]
I don't think you're turned on
oh you are
yes I think that's working normally
cheers I think I I'm jinxing the system
um
Dr kirkella
um my name is lavri and I represent the
Northern Ireland covid-19 bereaved
families for justice and as you're aware
her leadership has permitted me to ask a
couple of questions about your report
and about your evidence
the first question I want to ask you
about is about operation cygnus which
you refer to in your report and there's
a section in that
um which is about the four nations
response and um one of the lessons
identified Lesson Four
um says that meetings of the four Health
ministers and CMOS should be considered
best practice and included as part of
the response battle rhythm
and the report also notes
um that the devolved administrations
reported that they felt that they had
been left out from some key decisions
taken during the exercise such as the
decisions around activating the relanza
stockpile
do you agree that the lack of formal
involvement of the Northern Ireland
executive had a negative impact on the
executive's ability to prepare for the
pandemic
and first in relation to that the first
part is about whether
um
meetings between the four Health
ministers and CMOS of the four nations
formal meetings should be considered
um I mean it's always difficult to judge
from an absence uh what what the likely
reaction would have been it is
remarkable that more formal
meetings didn't necessarily take place I
believe the inquiry has already had
evidence that
representatives of the Welsh public and
also of the Scottish Public Health
System were on committees like Nerf tag
more in the function of their expert
qualifications rather than as a formal
part of the process
I think
as a historian it struck me as
remarkable that there's no more formal
representation of devolved
administrations there I can't comment on
on how that affected performance in
covid-19 because in your evidence
earlier you talked about the value of
informal relationships in particular
within the devolved Nations and would
you agree that if there were more formal
structures there and contact that might
lead to informal relationships so the
informal relationships are extremely
important between the public health
establishment and in all of the all of
the history witness seminars that I've
attended participants have stressed that
is extremely important to overcome
administrative misalignment in crisis
situations
I however had no doubt that more formal
discussions at the administrative level
would also improve coordination between
all four nations the more one talks
about common challenges uh the better
the solutions will be that come out of
them and would you agree then that
um you complained about this being with
Westminster led the preparedness that if
there was such a formal Arrangement that
it might be less likely to be
westminster-led
that is a political decision for the UK
populist to make how they want to
[Music]
um
organize
living together between the four nations
in the UK I think
that there is historically speaking a
bias towards English
experiences in the memory capture and
that that memory capture has informed
pandemic planning moving forwards and I
think that's all I can say there I think
it necessarily more diverse views will
likely create more resilience within the
system when it comes to thinking through
how
the same crisis can have different
impacts in different territories of the
UK
and that England might even learn from
the developed administrations I think
you said that there were some ambitious
initiatives from Northern Ireland which
founded because of a lack of government
there
um Northern Ireland is a very I think
specific historical case in terms of the
overall political environment in which
Health Systems reforms have been
attempted
I think that
the UK almost provides a natural
experiment for different forms of Public
Health Systems with each developed
Administration having slightly different
approaches towards public health and I
think that
um
the UK might profit from looking in more
detail at how Public Health can work as
an NHS only operation or within the
Northern Ireland context of an
Integrated Health and Social care system
lessons can be learned from every case
study and they come back to the one
point that is very important here is
that learning lessons also requires
comparable data and that is a big
problem well in that context next
question I wanted to ask you was you
noted that paragraph 138 of your report
that there were very few exercises which
were UK wide in scope
so is that part of the impact of that or
what was the impact of that
again I wish I'd had more time for the
report and for the archival
investigation the developed
administrations have lots of tabletop
exercises themselves
pathogens cross borders without thinking
of them so obviously any uk-wide health
threat even is a small outbreak will
probably trigger some kind of wider UK
response
so it seems logical and I'm thinking of
sort of a let one's evidence to the
inquiry to formalize uk-wide
preparedness planning going forward
then
also well at the paragraph 139 you refer
to the difficulties UK planners faced in
moving from tabletop exercises which you
discussed earlier in your evidence and
influenza plans to creating and
sustaining the real physical
infrastructures Staffing levels and
Regulatory alignment necessary for an
effective pandemic response does the
fact that similar concerns about the
UK's pandemic preparedness were
repeatedly raised throughout the
relevant period indicate that
a stated commitment to pandemic
preparedness was not reflected in the
action taken by government in the public
health sector during the relevant period
I think there is a mismatch between
public warnings about pandemics and
structural permanent reforms that I put
in place
and was you talked about the need to
adapt but also about the need for
resources
and with the position similar throughout
the UK or that vary across
um
Northern Ireland Scotland Wales and
England I'm I'm not sure I follow the
question well
you your concerns about
um the the during the relevant period
that the pandemic preparedness was not
reflected in the action tabletop
exercises were not
um reflected in real physical
infrastructure Staffing levels and
Regulatory alignment
um yeah so I mean um
again as as I said earlier you know
there it's it's one thing to have a
tabletop exercise it's another thing to
have a consistent policy implementation
Focus either at the UK level or within
the devolved administrations some
devolved administrations clearly pay
more attention to this than others and
again we come back to the point about
diversity and perhaps a lack of a whole
uk-wide approach to to these issues
and and finally then Dr Kirk Heller the
um
what was the impact of austerity
policies on this
um there's Blackwell in her evidence in
your evidence earlier
um put to the declining
um funding of Public Health and I think
you described it as a yo-yo effect
reacting to
um different situations was there an
impact
um of austerity on on these
I'm very sure that austerity and I think
the overwhelming body of evidence
collected by this committee speaks to
that oh by the inquiry speaks to it that
there was a negative impact on public
health levels the king's fund has
um published data also measuring life
expectancy changes during this time
changes in in developments of life
expectancy so I think there is quite a
large body of evidence with which I
would agree that austerity certainly
didn't have positive impacts on pandemic
preparedness the yo-yo effect is an
interesting one
um
often after Health emergencies you get
high levels of very targeted but often
very short-term funding for public
health and it comes back to the point
about that this funding rarely builds
what Philip mortimore was already
warning about in 2003 the long-term
capacity in the system because it goes
away after a while and it's often too
selective to build this core Baseline
capacity
in your summary you say that in Northern
Ireland there was I feel like a double
whammy impact of fiscal pressures and
sustained and regular periods of
breakdown of government storm and
stalemate
I draw here on the secondary literature
and so this is both from the European
health Observatory but also from social
scientists assessing it to describe
Northern Irish Health policy in between
the sitting of storm as managerial drift
and it's very difficult to prepare for
the future as a public health agency if
you're faced with significant political
uncertainty
both about your own administrative
Arrangements within Northern Ireland and
then obviously in the northern Irish
case specifically also the pending exit
of Britain from the EU which in the
annual reports also causes consternation
together with fiscal pressures together
with fiscal pressures yes
evidence Dr kirkeller thank you very
much indeed or your help Dr Keller you
kept saying her several times you've had
more time to do more research you've
done a huge amount of the time you've
had thank you very much thank you very
much
my lady the next witness is Professor
Sir Michael McBride
yes please
[Applause]
I swear by almighty God
the evidence I shall give shall be the
truth shall be the truth the whole truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth and nothing but the truth
foreign
good afternoon could you give the
inquiry your full name please yes sir
Michael Oliver McBride
so Michael thank you for the provision
of the two witness statements that you
have given this inquiry they are at
1-87-306
dated the 12th of May and 203 352 dated
the 6th of June
you've signed both of them and provided
statements of Truth
so Michael you are currently the chief
medical officer for Northern Ireland you
were appointed to that post in September
of 2006.
before then were you medical director at
the Royal group of hospitals from August
2002. that's correct
have you also during that period been
the chief executive of Belfast Health
and Social care trust a position you
held from December 14 to February 17.
yes so you will you were fulfilling that
task whilst you are also chief medical
officer that's correct yes
I'd like to start please if I may with
the position of the chief medical
officer for Northern Ireland and the
chief medical officer group in the
general scheme of things in Northern
Ireland may we have pizza r organogram
204014 at page 14.
you will see there
in the middle of the page the first
minister in Deputy first Minister the
executive office
and towards the bottom of the page
the blue box Department of Health
bottom right hand corner chief medical
officer group and chief medical officer
it is obvious that the chief medical
officer
is part of the chief medical officer
Group which is part of the Department of
Health could you please give us an
overview of the chief medical officers
functions as part of the Department of
Health yes
um as chief of medical officer my
main role is to provide independent
advice to the problem secretary to the
minister on
professional technical matters and on
scientific matters and I'm supported in
that role by a number of professional
colleagues I also have responsibilities
in heading up the chief medical officers
group for particularly population Health
directorate which you see in the Box
a population health directorate is
headed up by the director of population
Health who reports through to the deputy
chief medical officer of intern through
to myself
population Health director has
responsibility for a number of policy
areas which are of relevance to the
inquiry namely Health protection
including screening and vaccination and
also emergency preparedness and response
in terms of relevant policy and and
guidance it also has responsibility for
health Improvement policy so that would
be in relation to departmental policy on
alcohol and drugs on suicide prevention
and a range of other parted areas around
you know with respect to reducing Health
inequalities
that's quite a lot that's quite a lot
the CMO group obviously therefore
discharges functions beyond the
individual functions of the chief
medical officer so it from what you've
said appears to be concerned with health
protection policies vaccination
infectious disease prevention control
and health Improvement generally
where within that structure that's to
say the CMO group structure and the
population Health directorate structure
does the specific issue of emergency
planning in the health field come in
yeah I should add if I may before
answering that that there are a number
of other policy area direct trips within
CMO group and that includes the pharmacy
directorate which is headed up by the
chief pharmaceutical officer and also
Chief Dental officer Chief Dental
officer quality safety and Improvement
indeed indeed the responsibility for the
area that you mentioned resides within
the emergency planning Branch within CML
group and do we have that in the blue
box under Department of Health that is
correct
and does the emergency planning branch
have day-to-day responsibility for that
part of the Department of Health that's
concerned with the budgets for pandemics
and civil contingency planning and
preparedness
emergency planning and that area
it does I mean I can expand if that's
helpful but yes
the emergency planning Branch doesn't
report however directly to you as the
CMO does it
um ultimately it reports through to me
yes ultimately to you but does it report
through in fact your Deputy the deputy
CMO it would report through the director
of population Health then in turn to the
deputy CMO and ultimately to me so I
would have overall responsibility all
right so in in truth you are two stages
removed the reporting goes through the
director of population health and Miss
Redmond and then through her to the
deputy CMO and then to you correct
with the terrible tyrells of covid
behind you is that a structure which
works in your opinion or would you say
that the emergency planning Branch given
the importance
of the the matters which IT addresses
should it be closer connected to you the
CMO in a more direct reporting structure
I I think
the the span of that area of work within
population Health was too large I think
I would absolutely acknowledge that
since that organizational structure
there we have subsequently carried out a
review within chief medical officer
group we have established a separate
Health protection directorate and also
again to use that
acronym again the a separate directorate
for emergency preparedness resilience
and response which is headed up
expanded
those particular areas and reduced the
responsibilities of the director of
population Health accordingly and
appropriately I would add so to be clear
about this following covid you in fact
commissioned a review yes in 2021
as to whether or not the current
structure of the CMO group was
appropriate in terms of its ability to
prepare for emergencies and and
addressing civil contingencies and that
review recommended a new directorate
which is not a subdivision of the
director of population Health correct it
is now its own directorate the emergency
preparedness resilience and response
directorate that is correct so may we
take it from that that it now has a
greater prominence and importance in the
general scheme of things structurally
within the Department of Health
it certainly always had a prominence and
importance it certainly has now a
greater resource aligned to it and I
think that is you know it's a
distinction but I mean I think your
point and the premise of your point is
well made am I accepted it's a change
that you wouldn't have recommended and
put into place unless it had intrinsic
worth that is correct right
in your statement you say that the CMO
group is is the sponsor Branch at the
sponsor Branch for the public health
agency in Northern Ireland what does
that mean what is the sponsor Branch yes
um
the Department of Health has a number of
what we refer to as arms length bodies
those arms length bodies are established
in statured so the public health agency
is established in statute
um there are a series of agreements in
place in terms of
objectives business plans priorities
which are set on an annual basis in
agreement with the PHA which are set
against their annual allocation in terms
of their budget
as the CMO group and head of CML group
we meet with the PHA on a very regular
basis through what are called
sponsorship review meetings so those are
an opportunity
from a fixed agenda for the PHA to raise
issues that they have in relation to
meeting their objectives any resourcing
pressures that they may be encountering
or areas where they require us to
support them and engaging with other
depart parts of the department given
that their responsibilities particularly
around Health Improvement are
cross-cutting an impact on a number of
other policy areas within the department
so those sponsorship review meetings may
occur very regularly and then they also
feed into
the mid-year and end end of your
accountability review
with the permanent secretary which I
also attend along with the chief
executive of the health of the PHA
public health agency and the chair of
the board of the public health agency
all right
we are of course concerned with
the responses of the various bodies and
that the planning done by them in the
context of infectious disease outbreaks
in the northern Irish
Department of Health structure
which body
is primarily responsible for operational
response in the face of an infectious
diseases outbreak I ask because we have
in this structure as we we've now heard
the public health agency but milady's
had evidence that in the
civil contingencies part of the northern
Irish government the
ccgni there is a hub there is also an
emergency operational Center within the
Department of Health all of which would
be expected to carry out
operational responses so where does the
pha's operational functions come in the
general scheme of things the public
health agency will lead on
the vast majority of
outbreaks of infectious diseases I mean
if I could give for example coming
out of covert we had a number of
unfortunate
um
occurrences where we saw higher than
normal rates of infection
if you recall we saw scarlet fever in in
young children occurring more frequently
and indeed in in older people we had
an increase in a type of hepatitis known
a non-e hepatitis again which the PHA
was leading the Northern Ireland
response and in both those cases the PHA
was plugged in as it were to The Wider
UK response so the
um
the UK Health Security Agency
established an incident management team
at a UK level and then the public health
agency would manage the response at a
Northern Ireland level but liaising with
the UK Health Security Agency so in the
day-to-day management of outbreaks
whether that's foodborne for instance
they would work with local councils in
supporting the management of that
outbreak it would be the public health
agency it when it gets to a scale where
it's beginning to impact at a population
level then it's at that point we make a
decision within the department whether
we continue to keep a monitoring brief
or we need to lean in to support the PHA
and the um in the way to response which
you'll then do by triggering
the arrangements at a national level by
virtue of
the CC geni Hub by the operational
Center within Department of Health where
of course the emergencies are regarded
as a
as requiring that sort of national
response certainly at the extreme
escalation but there is a sort of an
in-between level where the public health
agency May determine
for instance look this outbreak is now
impacting on the Health Service
and they may say to colleagues in what
was the Health and Social care board we
need the resources of the Health Service
to support us in managing this outbreak
so the a good example was it was MPX
recently where the Health and Social
care board had to come alongside the PHA
to support the vaccination of those that
are were at significant risk
and at a further escalation
the PHA the public health agency that
social security boards may decide to
activate silver and in that case we
really at that stage would be thinking
look this is perhaps something which is
getting to the stage where it may be
affecting the Northern Ireland
population and then we as a department
would seek to support provide strategic
Direction provide advice and support
and if it really got to the level where
it became a civil contingency emergency
at that scale then that's when you would
see the triggering of the Northern
Ireland Hub the national Arrangements in
the National civil contingency
management Arrangement Etc all right
in your witness statement there are
references to two other groups that I
want to ask you about the first is the
Northern Ireland pandemic flu oversight
group
this appears to be a group that was
established by you in 2018
to lead on Health and Social care
preparedness and response and one of the
areas that it was addressing was the
promulgation of guidance for surge
capacity
and and also triage work by Healthcare
settings
it seems to have been established by the
emergency planning branch
the body to which you referred a few
moments ago and it was chaired by the
director of population health
what was the need for that body why was
it set up in 2018 shortly
um well in short this was a
following on from exercise sickness it
was identified at a UK level that there
was a need for surge plans right across
Health and Social care but a particular
reference to secondary care and social
care
uh there were five work streams set up
at a UK level in the summer of 2017
all of the devolved administrations were
part of that work
to ensure that Northern Ireland played
its full part in ensuring that we worked
within that structure
we established a
ccg sort of civil contingencies group
pandemic flu
Group which over to overlook those five
work streams I'm not going to the detail
of those but this pandemic flew
oversight group
beneath that then sat the Northern
Ireland pandemic flew oversight group
with a specific purpose of developing
surge plans in relation to secondary
care and social care as you say was
chaired by the director of population
health I'm going to take the liberty of
suggesting a correction in the
nomenclature was that the pandemic flew
Northern Ireland subgroup
yes right
that body
so the first one I mentioned the
Northern Ireland pandemic flu oversight
group was therefore formed to ensure
that the the work streams the
recommendations the learning from
exercise cygnus
were properly implemented and it
led to an additional group being formed
called the task and finish Group which I
think you asked the public health agency
and the Health and Social care board to
establish and that was then put into
place the following year in 2019. is
that correct yes
to clarify that because we're confusing
each other so there was the Civil
contingencies group
which was plugged into the pandemic flu
Readiness board so that was overseeing
all five work streams which the director
of population Health was also chairing
but uh Department of Justice steel we're
members of that
then beneath that was a health-specific
group which was in Northern Ireland
pandemic flew oversight group again
chaired and established by the
international publication Health
established in March and you're quite
right that beneath that is a subgroup
yes that was a subgroup of the group
I've just mentioned and then there was a
task and Finnish group as well we uh yes
uh that group the oversight group
comprised the department
senior executive directors within the
public health agency and the Health and
Social care board
I I wrote personally to the then chief
executive of the board asking them to
establish a task and finish group or
working for the PHA to develop the said
guidance and that was in 2019.
2000 November 2018 was the date of my
letter and the group was established in
2019 yes
an important function of that task and
Finnish group was to review and update
Health and Social care influenza
pandemic surge guidance
but as events transpired Sir Michael
although a draft was drawn up it was
decided by officials in these relevant
bodies the further work was required
but that work never came to pass because
of course the impact of the preparations
for a No Deal EU exit and then of course
covet itself
so the majority of the work that was due
to be done by that task and finish group
despite its title was never completed
and and therefore one may suppose
that um this structure of having
um
a Northern Ireland pandemic flu
oversight group then a subgroup and then
a task and Finnish group
alongside all the other groups largely
failed at least in relation to that
particular purpose
um I think well it's absolutely correct
to say that that work wasn't finished
for the reasons that you've outlined
both at a UK Level under the northern
level because resources were diverted to
EU exit planning the work was
incidentally picked up again in January
of 2020 but of course then events
overtook us of course and in the end
further work was carried out in February
and we did have surge plans in place for
the first wave of the pandemic but again
we'll be looking at that in later
modules I think it was um
I'm not some certain that I would
necessarily agree that it's a structural
issue in terms of complexity of the
structures
um you know I think it's actually all
about function and structured matter
less there are some structures that
matter work better than others
we did however make significant progress
in a number of areas the preparation of
the terms of the pandemic flu plan was
significant progress made in that but
again it wasn't completed I think it's
very we'll come back to the okay we're
planning a little later just remaining
on the structures
the inquiry is aware from your witness
statement and other material that there
are no there were I don't know whether
they are still in existence a number of
other bodies the health emergency
planning Forum the critical threats
preparedness Steering group The Joint
emergency planning board The Joint
emergency planning team
there may be an appearance here of an
over complexity or duplication of
function or perhaps a bit more
charitable
a rather diffuse structure
has the structural system in Northern
Ireland relating to
Healthcare
being the subject of any type of overall
analysis or rationalization
since covered
um
certainly there it is ongoing work in
relation to the review of the emergency
response plan
there has been reviews of the business
continuity plans
across the system in terms of the
structural elements that you've
described and how the interior lit I
know I have to say for those working in
the system
who need to know how those structures
work we know how those structures work
and how they interrelate and I can't
explain for instance the the various
joint emergency planning board The Joint
emergency planning team and how it
supports the board but I suppose really
I absolutely appreciate from those
looking in from the outside
it's a reasonable question to say is
there a simpler way of doing this I
think we structure the work in such a
way that we get the work done and
we put around it organizational
arrangements to ensure in as far as we
possibly can notwithstanding that there
are always other pressures other demands
and priorities that we get the work done
in his effective way as we can that's
the point isn't it I mean the overall
worth of a system is surely not to be
determined solely by whether or not its
participants understand what they're
doing it must also be determined by the
outcome and the output correct there are
significant areas in which the work
which was meant to be done by some of
these committees groups and entities
didn't come to fruition I think in the
specific examples that you mentioned yes
however there are other examples where
significant work was progress and did
come to fruition
and that work is ongoing
um on a on a daily weekly monthly basis
so on those specific elements that
you've mentioned yes while there was
significant progress made in some areas
more than others there were aspects
which certainly were not completed all
right
turning to another major issue in
Northern Ireland the
the collapse in the power sharing
Arrangements
it is obvious so Michael from the
evidence of Mr Swan last week and from
the material before the inquiry that the
lack of an executive particularly
between 2017 and 2020 had an adverse
effect on to use Mr Swan's words the
preparedness of the Health and Social
care system
in terms of Staffing it led to
inadequate Staffing levels
because key decisions simply couldn't be
taken by ministers in the absence of a
power sharing arrangement
and the loss of strategic political
oversight led to to use the words of the
permanent secretary stagnancy on the
part of the Civil Service to what extent
from your Vantage Point as the CMO
within the CMO group
did the collapse in the power sharing
executive have an adverse impact
um
maybe could I answer that in maybe three
parts I think there's sort of General
context which I I think is is relevant I
think that there is absolutely no doubt
um that the absence of ministers did
have a significant impact
on our ability to initiate new policy
develop new policy we were not in a
position to develop any relevant
legislation either primary or secondary
legislation
and given that all of the work on what's
referred to as the program for
government which is the cross-cutting
work approved by the executive where
government departments put to ministers
an agreed program of work for government
we missed out and lost out on that
um
the benefits of that that cross
government approach
I think specifically in relation to
health
there is no doubt that the it has been a
very challenging resourcing situation
over the over the last decade and
particularly so in Northern Ireland over
the last five years
compounded by a Reliance on annual
budgets
so we were making decisions
in terms of trying to live within budget
allocations so just to pause that so
that we may be clear about what you're
saying
one of the consequences the absence of
ministerial oversight is there is nobody
in position who can say well
you can be permitted to move outside
your budgetary constraints we can take a
different decision here in relation to
resourcing or Staffing levels because
you've made a persuasive case that there
ought to be a change
so in essence you have to Simply live
within your means and those means were
determined
of course before the collapse in the
power sharing Arrangements yes I mean at
that time there was limited ability for
permanent secretaries to make that those
sort of decisions that you've alluded to
and that was Guided by relevant court
rulings and the executive formation
functions act
um so you didn't have that same ability
to move resources around and align them
to priority
that certainly impacted on decisions
within Health where we had to make
savings and obviously there's limited
opportunity to make savings and health
particularly where you have got
inflationary pressures of six percent
per year
because of technology and aging
population and their needs
and we had in that the five years
running up to
1920 something in the region of a
2.90 growth on Baseline each year
leaving a
a gap of three percent every year on
year for five years
um making a deficit in your yes
a gap between what we needed
and what we had so
the resulting position was that we were
having to make decisions which were not
necessarily decisions that should be
made but decisions that had to be made
and in in addition
the inquiries had evidence that the
Keynote
uh report by Professor Rafael benger the
The Basque Country minister
uh he led I think an expert panel review
in 2016 called systems not structures
changing Health and Social care which
was
I think envisaged to
provide a framework for a significant
reform in their Northern Irish Health
and Social care system that report
couldn't be put into place either
um
that's partly true we were fortunate in
that that report had been published
prior to the collapse of the executive
and in October 2016 the then Health
Minister approved
the health and well-being 2026
delivering together which in essence
gave the political mandate and the
direction of travel for the
transformation of Health and Social care
services in Northern Ireland so we had a
mandate within health and we took
forward within the limitations of that
mandate a number of areas of work so we
developed a mental health strategy we
developed a cancer strategy we published
an elective care framework we undertook
a major review of unscheduled care
services such as an accident emergency
department and that's now going through
to the first phase of implementation and
just pausing you down I'm sorry sir
Michael no you're okay there's obviously
a gap between in planning and having
mandates and reviewing the position and
of course implementation which will
depend necessarily on resourcing
and you've agreed that of course during
the Hiatus there was no ministerial
directional resourcing and I completely
concur with that was the point it was
about to make which is that we put
together the building blocks we did some
very good work in terms of
what we would need to do but there were
clearly elements of of this that
required a ministerial decision and
those areas that required a ministerial
decision we were not possible it was not
possible for us to uh progress there was
progress made and I could give some
examples but
um happy to expand if that would be
helpful
the sum of that so Michael is that
although progress was made and
reviews and plans and guidance were
drawn up because as you say you had a
mandate
overall there was a negative impact from
the collapse in the power sharing
agreement because of the lack of
resources and the sharing ability to be
able to implement
both that report and the other reforms
and resourcing changes which were deemed
necessary that was the the sum outcome
if you like of
the absence of ministerial oversight I
think it had an impact
um I don't think there's any question of
that had we had ministers I think it's a
reasonable question to ask whether we
would have been able to take further all
of that work any more quickly because
the work still needed to be done to
inform ministerial decisions
but absolutely we there were significant
elements of it that we could not
Implement without a ministerial decision
may I ask you about the Department of
Health Department risk registers yes is
that a process in which the CMO plays a
significant role
um I certainly sign off on it uh it's
developed by colleagues uh within
um CMO group The relevant policy areas
and certainly would be brought to my
attention I would see the details of
that I would have an opportunity to ask
any questions seek any clarification uh
and ultimately as the risk holder would
approve that to be considered by a top
Management Group
and subsequently by the departmental
board may we have please one eight five
three seven nine which is the
2018-2019 Department of Health
Department risk register
the
this is Page 24 of the versions Michael
so that you can get your bearings in
relation to it and it shows a particular
risk Road dr6 in the bottom left-hand
corner
the Health and Social care sector may be
unable to respond to the Health and
Social care consequences of any
emergency including those for which the
Department of Health is the lead
government that I anticipate Department
due to inadequate planning and
preparedness which could impact on the
health and well-being of the population
now that of course doesn't reflect the
reality it is the identification of a
potential risk
if we go back up please to page 24
the rating given for the residual risk
and the risk once it has been treated
that is to say once it has been
mitigated or thought has been given to
how the risk may be reduced by a
response
the ratings are assessed to be high and
medium both for impact and likelihood in
both cases that's as a current untreated
and then a number of actions are
identified developing reviewing
strategic Frameworks developing pan flu
preparedness by participating in the UK
pandemic flu Readiness board leading the
ccgni subgroup
and over the page
work in relation to the contribution to
the UK draft pandemic Bill the
development of pan flu guidance for
Northern Ireland incorporating primary
secondary and social care delivering a
work program to include training testing
and exercising and then at the bottom of
the page management of Health
countermeasure stock parts
can you recall Sir Michael to what
extent
the identification of that risk was
debated within the cmog or the
Department of Health in 2018
particularly from August which has been
I think that was published or made
available
was there a significant level of concern
that that risk identified in the
left-hand side of the page was required
to be mitigated and
in essence things had to be done on
quite a number of fronts in order to
make sure that the risk could be
properly mitigated
I mean I kept recall the specific
discussions at that time but I would say
is that certainly going back as far as
when I took up posts in 2006 pandemic
flu and the risks associated with it has
always been on the departmental risk
register
um the normal process whereby that would
be assessed I would involve my receiving
the assessment of the risk as I said
have an opportunity to engage with the
team it would then be discussed on more
than one occasion in its development by
the top management group of the
department which includes the param SEC
in respective policy leads including
myself
and in due course would be approved
it would be considered then by the
departmental board who would have an
opportunity to interrogate it ask
questions ask for further work or
assurance
and then it is brought together and
finalized and then in due course it
would be reviewed on a quarterly basis
by the risk holder I.E me
by TMG
by the departmental board and then by
separate to that again by the depart
departmental audit risk and Assurance
committee which basically
provides assurances to the permanent
secretary
if there are any gaps in the risk
register or in the controls within the
risk register about which he should be
concerned
so were you the risk owner for this risk
dl6 yes um these are all corporate risks
departmental risks but the Approach at
that time was there had to be one
nominated uh risk holder and I was then
nominated and is that why your name
appears in column four under SRO for
senior responsible officer that's
correct yes
why
is the
column actions completed completion data
known are blank on this 2018 to 19 risk
register for this risk not not I should
say for other risk but for this risk
yeah because what we have here is a
template for completion
as opposed to a completed template but
there are other risks identified on this
document for which there are
completed actions yes but the point is
that this is a living document and it's
updated on a quarterly basis so that
column to the extreme rate which is the
action completed would inform the column
that you've highlighted in blue in terms
of what progress had been made or why
there had been no progress made in a
particular area so at the date of the
making available of this variant of the
risk register
this form of the risk register there
were no actions completed and therefore
nobody could write into that column
anything by way of actions completed
completion date or ownership no I don't
think that's a reasonable conclusion I
think that this I mean there will be
completed
um documents where these actions are
completed and I'm sure they can be
provided to the query from any
particular date so as I say it's a
living document and this is a a template
for completion by
January 2020
and the eve of covid and the making
available the subsequent risk register
presumably for
2019-2020 do you know whether or not
those actions which are identified as
being planned were completed
somewhere completed others weren't I
mean I can go through them if that would
be helpful to you yes that would be
perhaps we could start with the pandemic
flu preparedness program yes that was
completed the emergency response plan
was updated signed off in January at
2019 and published in February at 2019.
the pandemic view guidance for primary
secondary and social care we've just
alluded to that that was progressed but
not to completion that draft had been
received but it required further work so
it was not completed by January 2020.
that is correct but progressed but not
completed the work program for training
testing and exercising that was
completed the training was completed in
um
June 2018 with the full exercise of the
Emergency Operating
so that was the the setting up and the
the running of the Hub or the
departmental the Department emergency
operational Center
and that was in the context was the not
of operation yellowhammer
um
it certainly would have been related to
that but again uh it was also related to
prepare preparation for a pandemic flu
um it so happened that yellowhammer was
in the going on in the background as
well in terms of EU exit preparation was
there specific testing of the
operational Arrangements the the
emergency response Arrangements in the
context of planning or emergency
preparedness for infectious disease
um because I must suggest you that sure
it's clear that the Hub was operating
and for operation yellowhammer and also
the departmental emergency operational
Center it doesn't appear that they were
operating for the purposes of readying
the task force for pandemic planning I
mean I mean the EOC operates generically
irrespective of what the threat or
Hazard is it isn't a a specific
response mechanism or coordination
mechanism to a particular threat
um
so Michael that action planned was
deliver a work program to ensure clear
understanding of roles and
responsibilities of key responders
and familiarization with Key activities
and processes in the context of planning
and preparedness which could impact on
the health and well-being of the
population yes so rather different no I
think that's the point I'm making is
that the activity of the EOC is agnostic
to whatever the threat is its role
function
it's Communications in and out to the
department from the Health Service the
sharing of information across government
its support to myself if it's activated
as ensuring the Strategic cell is
agnostic to whatever the threat is so
it's about the process if informing
taking information in to inform
strategic Decisions by myself if I was
sharing gold and sharing that strategic
information out across other departments
and back out to the Health Service so in
many respects it's neutral in terms of
what the particular threat is so it's a
it provides a generic function
s yes
return at quarter past three
all rise
foreign
may we have backup please document 185
379 page 14 and a different risk this
time so Michael dr1
that available financial resources are
insufficient and are not deployed
effectively to ensure that essential
services are maintained
the risk
is identified based pre and
post-mitigation as high which is why
it's red
uh a number of actions are planned with
Target dates and identification of
ownership and then in relation to
actions completed completion date and
owner
the
essential position was this wasn't it
that as you identify in your witness
statement there was a shortfall
so resources were simply not enough to
be able to meet the anticipated demands
of the Department of Health
in your witness statement you say that
that's an acknowledged error
vulnerability for the Department
and you also make the point that
it was difficult then for the Department
to maintain Readiness at a high level in
anticipation of future pandemics and and
that it would be likely to remain so
can you just tell us please whether or
not this position continued
up to the time of the pandemic this is a
2018-2019 risk register was it the same
position throughout the entirety of 2019
and into 2020.
yes and probably has deteriorated since
that time
in your witness statement you also refer
to a report from the Department of
Health Emergency planning branch and a
Lessons Learned review it's dated in
November 2021 it's one eight eight seven
nine seven
page nine please
foreign
right at the bottom of the page training
validating and review
despite training from operation
yellowhammer during 2019 at the
beginning of the response there were
insufficient fully trained staff to cope
with the volume of information or the
pace of the pandemic
so
there wasn't just the resourcing issue
that had fed through to an absence or a
an insufficiency in the correct number
of fully trained staff to be able to
cope with the position
as the department went into the pandemic
yes there were probably two separate
aspects to that we we had 62 staff
trained but even that given the demands
of the the pandemic initially wasn't
sufficient and we had to go out for more
volunteers
the second
aspect that compounded it was the remote
working
we were not set up for the level of
remote working that was required and
that was a an added problem however that
was rapidly addressed so there is
absolutely no doubt that there were very
significant challenges during that
period and so in conclusion whilst
operation yellowhammer the operation for
dealing with the potential consequences
of a No Deal EU exit had some benefits
in terms of
IT interdepartmental training training
out members of Staff who could be
utilized to stand up for crisis
management
benefits are rising out of better
developed Supply chains a better
understanding of medicinal supplies and
how to get medicines in the event of
Border problems
none of that could take away from the
Stark reality which is in terms of
resources and training and
staff numbers
the Department of Health was in a pretty
woeful position on the onset of the
pandemic
I I wouldn't use the word woeful I think
it was a very challenging position
I think the challenges of the pandemic
were unprecedented we had a resource but
we did not have the strength and depth
that was required to mount what was an
extremely sustained response to the
panda the Lessons Learned documentation
shows there were insufficient staff
numbers going into the pandemic and
there was a resource shortfall in the
two years leading up to it that is
correct isn't old I think it's a fair
summary in but I think this was his
document that was also written at a time
with the experience of the first wave of
the of the pandemic
so that we're absolutely clear so
Michael that paperwork shows that
the pre-existing position on the onset
of the pandemic was a shortfall in
resources and insufficient numbers of
Staff it wasn't that the demands of the
pandemic revealed that there wasn't
enough resources to be able to deal with
the pandemic that ensued or that there
weren't enough numbers of staff to be
able to deal with the pandemic as it
developed it was that objectively the
department was insufficiently resourced
and insufficiently manned
at the moment of the pandemic strung
I think that it is fair to say that
there were very significant Staffing
problems uh you know I'm not I would
agree with that
there was capacity there was capability
there was training
but as we began to respond to the
pandemic even that was insufficient to
mount the response that was required of
course because the scale of the pandemic
yes was that with anybody's imagination
all right another topic please which is
the Health and Social care influenza
pandemic preparedness and response
guidance 2013.
is this the document which was produced
largely in Reliance upon the United
Kingdom 2011 pandemic influenza strategy
which was itself
based upon the learning and the outcome
from the H1 N1 swine flu and the report
from Dame Deirdre height in part yes so
there were three inputs to that document
the first as you say was the UK strategy
itself the second was the
recommendations
arising from Deirdre Heinz review and
the third element was then a sort of
Lessons Learned report that we did
internally within the department and
those three elements contributed to that
document yes
[Applause]
we've noted that the document is very
similar to the Welsh variant
that is to say the Wales Health and
Social care influenza pandemic
preparedness and response guidance
I'm not going to torment You by asking
which country prepared its guidance
first but but one or both of the two
countries must have had half a lie at
least on the other one's guidance I I
think it would be a normal practice we
work very closely together across the UK
in terms of developing guidance and we
will share documents with each other I
mean that I think that is a strength and
certainly we did share our document with
colleagues in in Wales but then again we
also benefit from colleagues in Wales
and Scotland and England sharing their
documents with us so I think that's a
strength which I hope continues
but all those strategies were all
themselves aligned to the United Kingdom
approach in 2011 about which milady's
had a great deal of evidence yes does it
follow Sir Michael that because of that
close alignment
the 2013 guidance may be said to have
suffered from the same strategic
errors if that is what my lady finds in
due course as the 2011 document the
absence of
detailed consideration of the variable
and inherently unpredictable
characteristics of a
pandemic uh zoonotic pandemic outbreak
an absence of
any debate about the consequences of
differing levels of transmission of
incubation periods of viral loads or
asymptomatic transmission and the like
I mean I think you know the 2011
document makes passing reference to the
ability to adapt
the UK pandemic plan I think it's
inevitably the case that with the
experience that we've now all lived
through that that document did not
provide any effective basis for
responding to the covert pandemic which
absolutely correct that our guidance was
based on that and
um you know as I've said my evidence
statement and has been said by others we
absolutely do need a pandemic flu plan
but we also need something that is more
generic
that is agile enough to be scaled up
very quickly but then can be specific
enough to be tailored to the particular
pathogen the particular virus or other
agent and then the particular control
measures put in place depending on how
it's transmitted
and indeed the risk assessment process
at the United Kingdom level and also
nationally now reflects the broader
range of scenarios which were absent
from that original strategy
and it had no consideration did it of
the need of mass diagnostic testing or
Mass contact tracing or mandatory
quarantines or self-isolation or any of
the countermeasures
which may have been sort of appropriate
for a non-influenza catastrophic
pandemic I think that's a fair comment I
think it makes reference to contact
tracing
however I do not believe it was
envisaged that contact tracing or indeed
Community testing would be taken to the
scale that we did subsequently in the
covid-19 pandemic so I would agree with
that
Northern Ireland is of course in a
unique position because it is a separate
Geographic entity
from the United Kingdom it shares a land
border with another country
why was that
why was why were those specific
characteristics of Northern Ireland not
reflected in its own 2013 guidance that
there is no consideration of what we may
call the the single Island
epidemiological issue
the strategy and the guidance was
drafted very much as if Northern Ireland
was the United Kingdom but there are
unique circumstances prevailing there
um again
this was a high level points is that
there is and always has been and remains
very close cooperation on a north-south
basis in relation to a whole raft of of
policy areas and we will come back to
that Mike I think in relation to the the
question that you ask there are probably
two main reasons for that one is a an
issue of scale
and the second is a
if I might put it a broadly a
constitutional issue in in terms of
scale we benefit hugely from being
integrated into the UK system in terms
of pandemic preparedness at all levels
both in terms of preparedness
uh planning and in response
we are a very small Department a very
small
group of departments we simply could not
replicate
the expertise that exists or indeed the
scale of work that it takes place within
the other jurisdictions and we're
depending on that at all sorts of levels
so we're dependent on it from the point
of view of scientific advice from the
from sage and the various expert groups
we're dependent upon it in relation to
the risk assessments from UK Health
Security Agency and from the National
Security risk assessment and we're also
dependent on it from the point of view
of response so in terms of the clinical
countermeasure measures management board
in terms of the procurement of PPE at a
national level the procurement of
vaccines
I do biotics
and we benefit from it as we discussed
earlier from all of the work that was
taken forward for instance through the
pandemic flu Readiness board in terms of
the
pandemic flu bill
so we could not in our own right
replicate all that and we are crucially
interdependent on that work that occurs
at a UK government level
why was it not open to
the Department of Health to replicate
that work to take the advantage and the
benefit of the scientific advice the
generic thinking
the guidance and the policies which had
been no doubt carefully thought about in
in London and promulgated throughout the
rest of the United Kingdom
and consider alongside that material the
obvious fact that Northern Ireland is
part of an island that
no pandemic would respect a landlord
over the Republic of Ireland and that
there were
obviously advantages in being part of an
island and that proper sensible
consideration of countermeasures would
pay due regard to that future but that
thinking is absolutely absent
I think that probably comes on to my
second part I absolutely agree with you
that the premise of your question that
uh pandemics new new borders
the Constitutional reality is that we
are part of the United Kingdom of course
and in relation to sit you know Reserve
matters such as international travel for
instance that was an important
consideration in the pandemic that is a
matter which is reserved
if one considers also then as part of
the response in terms of the funding
the procurement of vaccines the funding
of furlough we are crucially dependent
on the UK government
to provide that and when the Cobra is
activated and the UK civil contingencies
arrangements are activated Northern
Ireland is part of that so I think the
question is probably
not a tactical issue for myself rather a
policy decision for ministers as I've
alluded to in my statement I think there
is real strengths and would be much
Merit in considering all of this
at a UK and Ireland level indeed I would
extend that across to the common travel
area it because again pandemics don't
respect borders and there is freedom of
movement of people within the common
travel areas there should be so
I did allude to exercises which test
that not just at the operational level
not just the policy level but also at
the ministerial level
let me put the question in a different
ways Michael it is obvious and there's
no significance in this feature it's
well known that there are a number of of
sophisticated and significant
cross-border entities which look at
matters which cross the land Border in
the island of Ireland
you've given examples of bodies dealing
with obesity prevention the all-ireland
food poverty Network the north south
alcohol policy Advisory Group the
British Irish Council work stream
is work on suicide prevention
cross-border and there is as we've heard
last week the cross-border Emergency
Management Group so there's no surprise
no
the existence of the Republic of Ireland
and the southern part of the island of
Ireland is is an obvious feature
so my question to you though is given
all that why was there no consideration
epidemiologically
in that guidance and 2011 guidance to
the strategies the policy documents that
followed the 2013 Gardens in the case of
the the
Department of Health
two
the obvious feature
that it is a single epidemiological
Island and that any sensible debate of
countermeasures and the spread of a
virus would have to take that into
account well I think it's if if I may
say so I think it's broader than the a
single epidemiological unit that is the
island of Ireland it goes much further I
think that involves the UK and the
island of Ireland and I think that's the
point that I was was making that I think
that is a policy matter for respective
governments to consider uh although I'm
well with my area of compliments to
speak on the responsibility of
governments but I do think that that is
a matter for governments to consider
those interfaces now there are
mechanisms uh in relation to you
mentioned the British Irish Council
Etc there are mechanisms in place
at a very practical level
um in terms of and answering the
question about common epidemiological
Approach at an operational level at a
chief medical official officer level we
did take common epidemiological
approaches to the Border counties where
we often had hot spots one side of the
border the other side of the border and
we requested the chief medical officer
in the Republic of Ireland and myself
requested the public health agency and
the Health Service executive to work
collectively along with local government
broadcast media Civil Society in
addressing those hot spots so at a very
practical reality that works once
forgive me once the pandemic had started
you met weekly with your counterparts
yes the Republican yes of Ireland in
order to address that obvious feature of
of your your joint position from the
island so
so that only highlights though the
absence of any sort of debate or
formalized or regular meetings to do
with pandemic preparedness in advance of
I mean the point I would make is we did
exactly the same in 2009 during the H1
and one pandemic so at a at a at that
level there is very good and effective
cooperation always has been at the
operational level at the operational
level supported by respective chief
medical officers I think the wider
question in terms of could we could the
Improvement at a UK government Irish
government level you know is a matter
matter for others because there are
there are there are policy decisions in
that space and a good example of that
was the alignment or a non-alignment of
international travel restrictions at
various points in time I mean I think a
relevance if I could give an example
very briefly was discussion of the
executive with the first Ministers of
um Scotland Wales and the uh
Chancellor of the Duchess of Lancaster
about a sort of five Nation two Island
approach and I think that's the sort of
space
um that we do need to think about uh for
the future and any future pandemic
pandemic preparedness all right
Chief scientific advisors
in Northern Ireland there is no General
Chief Scientific Advisor for the
northern Irish government for the for
the executive
but there are two csas are there not one
attached to the executive office and a
second attached to your own Department
the Department of Health
was it apparent prior to the pandemic
that there was a Lacuna in the system
insofar as there was no General
unattached
Chief Scientific Advisor for the
government
just to take it back a little bit
um there are two Chief scientific
advisors one within uh Department of
Health and the second one within the
department
d-a-e-r-a I'm sorry yes uh Department
agriculture environment rural Affairs
there is a second interim
um sort of Chief government uh
Scientific Advisor that has been
appointed as an interim and as you heard
from um Dennis McMahon's evidence there
have been a number of attempts to
appoint a substantive government Chief
Scientific Advisor but that I mean the
point is well made that there is not a
central uh government Chief Scientific
Advisor I think that is an inherent
weakness and the CSA role was at least
pre-pandemic part-time
it's obvious that very little advice was
sought from
Professor Young Who was the
Scientific Advisor for the Department of
Health
no again I I did hear that in questions
and evidence provided
um
during Robin Swann's session it is it is
not accurate to state that the
departmental of departmental Health
Chief Scientific Advisor did not provide
advice to the department he provided on
an ongoing basis on a number of really
important areas such as the Health and
Social care research and development
strategy the Northern Ireland genomic
strategy the Northern Ireland rare
disease strategy but that advice was
provided to the Department of Health I
think that and so may not have found its
way to the executive office and to the
attention of
yes I think that's the point set
um Professor young was making that he
had not been asked to provide advice
directly to the executive just a
statement of fact
so there is a there is a plan for the
future recruitment of a a chief
governmental or governmental Chief
Scientific Advisor can you say to what
extent those plans
um have developed I mean that's been
taken forward by the executive officers
I understand so I couldn't really
comment on the detail of that all right
um
within the Department of Health was
there any contribution to the issue of
pandemic preparedness
on the part of the CSA within the
Department of Health
uh no the contribution to pandemic
preparedness apart from myself would
involve the two deputy chief medical
officers
the senior medical officer for health
protection who would have provided
specific scientific Public Health advice
and other colleagues within the public
health agency as necessary
so the role of the departmental chief
Scientific Advisor was really in
response mode where with myself he would
support me in providing a scientific and
public health advice to the health
Minister and to what extent was the
departmental CSA linked into the UK CSA
Network
or to the
the well-known committee's concern with
disease and emergency outbreaks for
example sage and Spivey and nerve tag
and hairs and so on I mean we benefit
hugely from those expert committees and
our
representation on them in whatever
capacity either as observers or as full
members
um I think as so Chris Whitney mentioned
in his evidence of a very Salient point
which is that there's a difference in
rigor and coordination in slow time I.E
not in an emergency as opposed to an
emergency situation such as the pandemic
they worked extremely well during the
pandemic I think there needs to be a
further look at an examination of how
they are coordinated at other times
Professor young was able to to get the
benefit of sage because of course he
became a full-time attendee from March
2020 onwards yes prior to that time
Northern Ireland had only Observer
status to do not on stage it wouldn't
necessarily be invited to attend
um certainly I attended meetings in
February
um elf Sage a number of of CO2 meetings
I think it's fair to say that there were
many demands for a number of meetings
over that period that was often
difficult to attend meetings and also I
think as you've heard from other
Witnesses initially those were on
conference calls and the sound quality
was not good
um
and certainly throughout the pandemic
the uh and particularly after the return
of the chief science Civic advisor from
a period of of Upson Studio Health uh
the department was represented by either
himself or his Deputy because we
appointed a deputy for a period at all
of the uh Sage well certainly almost all
of the CH meetings but it's obvious
going forward that in respect of any
health emergency affecting
Northern Ireland there must be full
participation by its officials on the
relevant bodies including Sage yes I
mean I think sir Chris covered this as
well I mean the only person that was
entitled to full-time membership is a
chair and obviously it depends on the
nature of the emergency uh certainly if
it's a health emergency I think that my
belief is that there would be absolute
requirement for us to be full members
from the outset
do you know what the position is in
relation to the jcvi The Joint Committee
on vaccinations and immunizations and
also the AC the advisory committee on
dangerous pathogens are they committees
on which Northern Ireland has Observer
status or full participant status we
have observed our status on both of
those committees in relation to jcbi we
uh from 2015 we have
both Observer status and also an
individual who is now a full member of
jcpi and I'm also able to attend
subgroup meetings of jcvi so we are well
represented on jcpi
you in April of 2020 established the
Strategic intelligence group
chaired by the CSA I presume from your
Departments of the departmental CSA and
including members from a number of
August universities and academic
institutions and the PHA and also I
think members of urine Department as
experts why if you were receiving
sufficient scientific and Technical
advice from the UK bodies was it
necessary to set up the Strategic
intelligence group
um I mean it is good practice that um
the provision of scientific advice is
open to uh scrutiny
um and up until the establishment of
this strategic intelligence group that
the coordination of that advice uh to
ministers was being provided by myself
with input from Professor Young
and the two deputy chief medical
officers we felt that without seeking to
replicate or second gas Sage we felt
there would be much Merit in a wider
group of individuals considering not
just the sage advice but other
Publications other evidence emerging
from other parts of the world and
actually to take that and apply it in
the context of the trajectory of the
pandemic in Northern Ireland so it I
have to say it was very useful it
applied at one sort of degree of remove
challenge to us in terms of our thinking
which then informed Our advice to the
health Minister what about forecasting
and modeling was the system pre-pandemic
adequate for the purposes of providing
the executive with sufficient
information about modeling and
forecasting in the event of a
pandemic we certainly improved it we did
have full access to Northern Ireland
specific modeling from the subgroup of
spy M which a subgroup of sage
that was specific to Northern Ireland
but it wasn't as current and real time
as uh we wished so I asked the chief
Scientific Advisor on his return to
establish the Northern Ireland modeling
Group which he did
that continued then to provide as close
to real-time modeling and various
scenarios as we possibly could at a due
course I directed The PHA to build that
capacity and capability
into their organization which has not
happened so we we now have that capacity
within the public health agency but you
ordered the capacity to be to be set up
under the the guidance of the CSA and
then laterally onto the PHA because the
provision of information that you were
receiving pre-pandemic or at least on
the outset of the pandemic was not
sufficient for your purposes
I I wouldn't go as far as to say that
what I would say is that it was
sufficient but it wasn't as real time as
we would wish it to be and what is
really important as we've heard from
previous
um
uh Witnesses is that we take the data
that we have which was Northern Ireland
specific and we ensure that is as close
to real time uh and projecting potential
scenarios as we can to assist ministers
in their decisions
all right
um exercises and the outcome of SARS
following
um SARS
did the Department of Health carry out a
one-day exercise called exercise Goliath
yes I struggled to remember this earlier
when you mentioned it it was before your
time I should say well before my time
but it does take me back in time because
it was 2003.
um
however I was and did take part in that
exercise it was then the medical
director and the uh
in the Royal group of hospitals trust as
it was then the predecessor of the
Belfast Health and Social care trust and
did take part in that exercise now its
relevance is that within the lessons
that are identified following the
exercise
um was this lesson that operational
contact tracing mechanisms with the
potential for scaling up need a scaling
up need to be developed at board and
Trust level
a further recommendation revolved around
the fact that there appeared to be
insufficient discussion heard on primary
prevention to avoid spread of the
assumed
um SARS coronavirus and also that
participants in that exercise had voiced
concerns about contact tracing capacity
indeed and the questionnaires filed by
the participants almost every
participant mentioned the absence of
sufficient contact tracing capacity
that was a long time before 2020 of
course but many of the aspects of the
the system or at least the inadequacy in
terms of sufficient Mass testing Mass
contact tracing and the need to prevent
spread at an early stage of the outbreak
can all be traced back to some of the
concerns expressed following exercise
Goliath
and I wanted to know therefore
what you knew of the extent to which
those recommendations and concerns have
been acted upon
I'm as I say not in a position to to
answer that
um I
I would assume that as is normally the
case that those recommendations would
have been progressed and taken forward
to updates of the emergency response
plan which I think was first developed
in uh from memory in 2009 that is an
assumption I can't say that with
absolute certainty but it didn't provide
for Mass contact tracing or surge
capacity sure on the level which was
anticipated in the recommendations from
exercise Goliath you know and I think
that they're in is the difference
because again this was you know looking
at correct rightly or wrongly through
the lens of a high consequences
infectious disease
with a very limited potential to become
a pandemic so it wasn't looking at these
requirements through
like we need this for a pandemic it was
looking at are these needed now for this
High consequences infectious disease
which has limited compared to
coronavirus as our score and virus 2 has
limited person to person risk of
transmission except particularly in
those who are in close contact such as
in a healthcare environment so I think
that that I suppose leap of thinking and
challenge in terms of thinking did not
occur I can only assume in terms of
whether these are capabilities that we
may need to deploy
in a scenario where we're dealing with a
novel uh pandemic virus and this comes
back to the original strategic error if
you like in the uh I think that's a fair
common strategy what about exercise
cygnus the exercise sickness Focus for
the purposes of Northern Ireland
on issues concerning communication with
UK scientific experts communication with
the UK government and cross-border
cooperation of the Republic of Ireland
by the time of the pandemic had all
those issues or recommendations been
implemented or were there still concerns
as the Department of Health saw it by
January 2020. well certainly as as we
covered earlier there were a number of
elements of work which informed the five
work streams under the pandemic flu
Readiness board which some of which have
been progressed further than others but
certainly not all completed
in relation to
um exercise cygnus we did provide and
put back to inform the Lessons Learned
report that was produced at a UK level
but we also developed our own Lessons
Learned reports and we identified 10 key
areas uh to be progressed of those six
were completed
uh there were two that we didn't
complete and couldn't complete because
it involved one of them this
recommendation two involved a review of
the UK strategy of 2011.
um the recommendation five involved a
completion of the communications around
pandemic flu now we had submitted our
updated action in April 2018 and there
was one recommendation which we will
never complete because it's about
ongoing review and validation and
updating
in relation to the Health and Social
care system yes so
um we did make significant progress on
the recommendations that we had
identified but there are a number
um of recommendations within sickness
which I think has already been covered
in the evidence of others that were not
completed
could we have one eight eight seven
seven six please
this is a report from November 2018.
concerning the delivery of the Civil
contingencies group Northern Ireland
resilience program
progress report is called a progress
report template
and you can see that by November 2018 it
asserts that good progress has been made
on a number of areas but there are at
the bottom of the page a number of
issues still requiring resolution excess
deaths and then over the page
that is on track
do you know whether or not that
particular recommendation that
particular issue of excess death was
completed could we just go back sorry
yes what was on track sorry
um deaths
I think um
what I wasn't directly involved in that
work at uh as you say the Department of
Justice is leading or not I think
significant progress was made I'm not
certain whether that was completed and
then sector resilience the middle of the
page the executive office is in the
process of collating information for
issue to departments to commission
resilience assessments for their
respective sectors what is sector
resilience
it's the refers to in simple terms the
preparation
for the
non-health related consequences of a
pandemic so the impact across broader
Society the impact on the economy the
impact on education
the impact on our range of other other
sectors again that area of work and that
coordination of work on the non-health
pandemic consequences
Falls to to deal to progress all right
and then do we take it that the first
bit upon resilience and Health and
Social care the Preparatory work to
establish a group to draw up
service-facing surgeon triage guidance
was the work to which you made reference
at the beginning of your evidence that's
correct
which due to the demands of operation
yellowhammer and then the onsets of the
pandemic was never completed
the risk register for the Department of
Health at the time to which we looked
earlier made plain that the Health and
Social care sector might be unable to
respond to the Health and Social care
consequences of any Emergency due to
inadequate planning and preparedness so
may we take it from that that there was
a general awareness that important parts
of
the post cygnus recommendations
because of the demands of lack of
resource and insufficient staff numbers
were not being brought to fruition
um
sort of distinction of her mates the
and I hope this is clear the purpose of
a risk register is to ensure that the
objectives of the department are met
and clearly the department has a
responsibility to provide Health and
Social care services in whatever
circumstances
so the purpose of the risk register is
to delineate
some of the critical risks
it's not to say there's a significant
risk that's going to happen it's saying
this is a risk that we need to be very
mindful of this is a risk we need to be
prepared for and we need to take a range
of mitigation beginning medicating
actions to prevent that from happening
um these are the those that fall to
Health in terms of which we discussed
earlier are some of those mitigations
they're not all of them but they are
some of the mitigations because it's not
an exhaustive list it's some of the high
level uh mitigations that went into the
departmental risk register but not all
the mitigations
were put into effect for the reasons
that you've described yes so the risks
of course
continue to to to exist because they
were not all met
by way of the mitigating measures for
the reasons you've described and the
only other point I would make is that
risk will always remain on the risk
register because it is a material risk
that will continue to remain on the risk
register as it has done from 2008 is it
a risk that we always need to be mindful
of so so it's never resolved
um it always needs to remain as a risk
and as I say there's a need to update
the actions that we will take to manage
the risk quite but because it was a high
level departmental risk register the
department at a high level was aware of
the risks of course and the absence
in pause
of the proper mitigating steps been
taken to mitigate the risks
in in part but as I say there are a
range of other mitigations that are in
place that are not necessarily reflected
in the Department's risk register but
will be reflected in the risk register
of other organizations who will be
mounting the operational response so
this is a very high level departmental
document one of the other pieces of
learning that came out of exercise
cygnus was the need to collaborate on
cross-border issues and quite operate a
joint up strategy with the Republic of
Ireland
we've debated already some of the bodies
sure to which you personally were were
party
did the system of cross-border
collaboration improve after 2016 and the
outcome of cygnus before 2020 or was it
in a in a state of
statism
um I can only comment from my own
experience and knowledge
um
you know from taking up posts in 2006
there's always been very effective
working relationships between
both departments but that's not really
the question as to whether or not the
recommendations in respect of
cross-government collaboration will
progress and taken forward by UK
government and they engaged with the
Irish government I I couldn't say all
right
inequalities and data disaggregation in
your witness statement you refer to the
development of a vulnerable people
protocol to Define vulnerable people and
I think it was your team that developed
the protocol in order to try to identify
persons who would need particular
assistance of course in the event of a
pandemic when was that protocol drawn up
it was pre-pandemic was it not yeah from
memory it was drawn up and completed in
2013 following a particularly severe
episode of severe weather that Northern
Ireland experienced at that time so 2013
from recollection and then was it
subject to variation throughout and then
operated but utilized at the time of the
pandemic yeah I think it was updated in
in 2016
um
I mean it
I don't know if you want to expand on
the approach taken or but I was going to
ask you was it a protocol that
paid attention to the clinical needs of
vulnerable persons or was it a protocol
that was able to identify
vulnerabilities ethnically and socially
as well
um it was more of a generic document so
um the approach the initial thinking of
this was that we could develop a list of
lists
uh with the appropriate Safeguard to I
did a protection and personal
information of vulnerable people right
across Northern Ireland obviously that
wasn't possible so it as it was
developed it was agreed that we would
um develop an approach which is based on
those known to Health and Social care as
a vulnerable like that can be for a
variety of reasons
um it doesn't necessarily relate to
clinical vulnerability there could be
other reasons why people are socially
vulnerable so there was no one to the
Health Service
those
um no one to utility services for
instance heat light and Par who would be
on their list as particularly vulnerable
and then we had a third category which
was the emerging vulnerable
um because obviously in any particular
emergency situation there can be people
who emerge
as the emergency progressors who were
not immediately obviously vulnerable at
the outset so that was the approach that
was taken and you may not be known to
the authorities may need to be
discovered yeah and was that protocol of
great practical utility in the face of
the pandemic itself I I don't believe it
was a great practical utility if I'm
honest
um I think the nature of the decisions
that were made the speed at which they
were made the fact that we were making
decisions which were about saving lives
uh protecting the Health Service May
meant that we had to make ministers had
to make decisions based on the advice
that we were providing
which didn't allow us the time to
consider as fully as we uh
perhaps on reflection could have the
impacts the disproportionate impacts
that some of those Norm pharmaceutical
interventions the restrictions on
people's lives were having on those who
were most socioeconomically
disadvantaged because of course
those countermeasures the decisions were
taken at a very high generic level they
were they applied Across the Nation and
it was simply not possible to have
regard to the particular characteristics
which might have underpinned a more
vulnerable Centric approach to
social restrictions yeah I mean I would
agree with that I mean we did
um whenever we were reviewed the
restrictions which we did on a three to
four weekly cycle we did give
consideration to those who would be
particularly uh adversely impacted
um
and there were certain mitigations that
we put in place to try to address that
so we worked very closely for instance
with the department for communities to
try to provide the requisite financial
support and other support to those who
were vulnerable those who were elderly
those were living alone
um
we worked we identified for instance
um that school I think we're moving on
to respect yes no I was going to let I
was going to let Michael finish that
particular answer
um finally one one last area so Michael
much of your two witness statements
um are devoted to the important issue of
lessons
and
in essence summarizing what you say you
appear to say this
that research capacity was of enormous
utility it was a great strength in the
United Kingdom and you were able to to
take the benefit of it in Northern
Ireland
for the future
the best thing that could be done to
ensure that we have the
capacity the generic skills to be able
to meet the next pandemic is to keep
that
research base in place to make sure that
we have the scientific wherewithal to be
able to respond to the next pandemic but
also this crucially the training of a
core group of individuals with
transferable skills who can then be used
to to use the current nomenclature scale
up
to the next Health Emergency
is that the nub of it
yeah
um
there are a number of issues which we
need to maintain capacity I mean the
Temptation is always once an emergency
is over is to move on to the next
set of challenges
and the resulting pressures are such
that there's a high risk that that will
happen
our science-based our research space
served us extremely well one area where
we are deficient as you've heard already
is around Diagnostics the ability to
scale that speed
in relation to your question
um there is there is a need for all of
government to see this as part of the
day job
this isn't an add-on extra
that those who are experts in emergency
preparedness and planning response do
we will need those individuals and
continue to need those individuals who
have those highly specialist skills and
experience and they need to be
acknowledged they need to be maintained
but we also need a set of generic skills
right across government and all
government departments so that an
effective response can be mounted and we
can dial that capacity up and dial it
down as the need arises because
unfortunately
we will not be able to maintain
the level of response responsiveness at
the level that it currently is but we
absolutely will need to be able to scale
that up at very short notice when the
need arises
thank you
you've gone to permission
for two broad areas of questions I
believe
to go live can can I be heard thank you
um so Michael my name is Brenda Campbell
and together with my colleagues here and
in Belfast we represent the um Northern
Ireland covered bereaved families for
justice I have been granted permission
to ask a question across two broad
topics and and I recognize from the I
said that to some extent they have been
covered but I wonder if on behalf of of
the northern Irish bereaved I might
address some further issues in relation
to them the first is in relation to
funding for the public health the agency
or perhaps more broadly Public Health
Services in Northern Ireland
um I don't know if you listen to the
early stages of evidence that my lady
heard but we we heard from professors
bambra and Marmot are those named your
nodings I I I'm assuming you you tuned
into their evidence
but in their report and in their
evidence they told us that the UK fell
from being ranked 26th globally in terms
of life expectancy in 2010
to 36th globally by 2020 so one per year
if in fact it was not more rapid at
different times
they went on to say that life expectancy
growth started to stall across the UK in
2011 something had changed in 2010 and
2011 and it coincided with a new
government who stated its ambition was
austerity and we heard some evidence in
relation to that this morning from Dr
Kokila as well and his reference to the
king's fund now you're noting because no
doubt those statistics are are
worryingly familiar to you in your role
as a chief medical officer indeed chief
executive of the Belfast Health and
Social care trust across that period
when it comes to Northern Ireland I
wonder if we could put up please Dr
kirkella's
um
uh expert report it's inq 30205-178
and I'm hoping it's page 79 in paragraph
124 which deals specifically with
Northern Ireland
so it's two zero five one seven eight
and paragraph
124 please
there we go do you see it it just goes
across two pages I I think
so Dr kakella in his report notes that
between 2010 and 2019 the provision of
Northern Irish Public Health Services
was subject to numerous reviews while
suffering from a stagnating or reduced
funding and political status
following its creation pha's overall
budget for health protection almost
halved from 8.4 million in
2009-2010 which was 15 of total program
funds
to four and a half million in 2012 to
13. seven percent of total program funds
before Rising back to 7.7 million still
only 10.6 percent of total program funds
in 2014 and 2015. and he observed that
budgets during the second half of the
2010s remain relatively static with the
public health agency at times resorting
to voluntary redundancies to save costs
which negatively impacted on staff
morale
that that shines to some extent with the
evidence that you were able to give us
this morning and should we understand
that your evidence is that the situation
has not improved since if anything the
situation has deteriorated since and I
say I don't recognize the detail of
those figures in relation to health
protection but I'm happy to talk
generally about the public health budget
allocation well that might be um for a
future module but certainly where Dr
kakella leaves off in 2019. the
situation is that the public health
agency has suffered from real-term
reductions over a decade-long period and
what the bereave families really are are
interested in is the is the impact of of
that on pandemic preparedness
um did you hear the evidence last week
from Mr Swann
I did you did and he um told us and it
was um dealt with in in some terms this
morning and again in your evidence about
the need for transitional funding to be
available in Northern Ireland not just
so that the Health Service could keep
going but so that very much needed
reform could take place and you agree
with that evidence I have no doubt in
relationship I do yes Mr swan
what what he went on to say was that the
impact of that or the consequences of
that were once there was Readiness for
some aspects of pandemic planning
the aspects where we'd actually fail to
invest in former Health Service had an
adverse effect on how we responded as a
Department of Health and as a society in
regards to the additional supports that
we had
so although there was some Readiness
essentially the Health Service was
ill-equipped to cope
with the requirements of the pandemic
would you agree with that
plans and preparation are really
important
but one of the most crucial aspects
uh of the ability to respond to any
emergency particularly sustained one or
a pandemic is the resilience of the
Health and Social care system
I think it is fair to say and this is a
a personal and professional view
that the Health Service in
2020 was not as resilient as it even was
in 2009 with the H1 and one pandemic and
there are a number of reasons for that
we've alluded to some of them the lack
of structural change which was
compounded by
the resourcing situation and as I said
earlier decisions that were made to live
within budget allocation are supposed to
decisions that should be made and as a
result that resulted in decisions that
were short-term
and in the long term counter-strategic
unlikely to cost more particularly in
relation to the priority that needs to
be afforded Public Health
well one practical uh consequence
is that you've told us that certainly as
a significant part of your role in terms
of planning there was a recognition of a
need for surge plans and for surge
capacity within the Health Service and
social care as well new degree with that
that there was a task and finish group
that was to review an update a pandemic
an influenza pandemic surge guidance
although that wasn't quite completed it
was Cameron Sergeant Trump you do seem
to be straying somewhat from I think
these are matters that Mr Keith has
already covered
um in fact malaria I hope I'm not
straying too much they've to put it into
the context of the evidence that we
heard from Mr Swan last week
um if I may it's it's in fact the last
topic under
um under this heading
and it was only
um if I
um
look at the question in particular
it's about how the impact was was
mitigated with her focus on and just to
use the example of surge given that it
was with evidence from last week and
indeed evidence from from today
um
The Surge capacity we were told
last week in the event of the pandemic
had to come from redirecting
or standing down other services so what
you give to kovid you take from other
areas and my question to you is this
um given the recognition of this as an
issue what did you do to ensure that the
impact was mitigated and that there was
or would be additional surge capacity
um I think
my concerns about the resourcing
position
in relation to the Health Service and
Northern Ireland or a matter of public
record
um
my concerns about the lack of structural
change or the slowness with which
structural change have been progressed
are also a matter of public record
I certainly raised those concerns
with within the department
there were difficult choices that needed
to be made
you mentioned the PHA budget
whilst they were not significant Cuts
per se the public health budget they had
to realize saving so there were they had
to absorb
for instance you know six percent
additional course in their admin budget
now when you talk about admin and the
public health agency that's professional
staff who their salary costs are not
insignificant so it's not as the same as
admin costs elsewhere and similarly they
have to absorb a reduction of some 4.3
percent in the Years running up to the
period in question in their program
budget now the program budget is the
things that you do in relation to
alcohol and drugs and other
interventions to address health and
equality I can't specifically comment on
the this figure in relation to health
protections it seems odd that was down
in one year and up and the next but
again public health agency colleagues
may be able to Enlighten
um you on that in terms of surge
um I think certainly as chief medical
officer I was leading at that point in
time significant elements of the Bengal
work so I was the senior responsible
officer for
the establishment of the day elective
centers to reduce the burden on their
Health Service and to have more people
having their surgery on a in you know
day case basis that was put to good
effect during The Surge because it meant
that some of the red flags Etc could
continue and we weren't having as much
an impact on routine elective although
we did significantly impact on people
waiting for routine elective surgery I
could give other examples but I am
conscious of of time so I I did what I I
could in terms of
helping ship influence and provide
leadership to that system change to
ensure that with the resources that we
had that we were really structuring at
the health service to ensure that it was
as robust as it could be to address any
intended pressures I have to say who
however that was largely to deal with
the here and I you know in Northern
Ireland Health Service struggles on a
day and daily basis to deliver what
should be delivering
um
notwithstanding the additional pressures
created by the pandemic and Surge and if
you're quite right really what we had to
do was turn off to a large extent all of
that elective capacity which had huge
impacts right across uh the public and
people within excessive periods of time
even longer than they were before or the
worst waiting times in the UK got even
longer people waiting in pain and
distress and we still are not the
position where we can recover that as
quickly as we would wish
thank you my lady I'm sorry to rise to
my feet I Believe Miss Campbell may have
had the 10 minutes that she was agreed
it was agreed that she would have and
I'm very well aware that the inquiry for
good practical reasons can't set past 4
15 today exactly what I'll do is um as
Campbell may I suggest I ask the
question that I gave you permission to
ask just to finish off because we are
under pressure I'm afraid of different
reasons
um
so Michael
were pressures on the PHA exacerbated by
uncertainty about regulatory
Arrangements amidst the UK's pending
exit from the European Union as
described by
um other people including baroness
Foster who's talked about the focus on
brexit and Dr kirkella this morning
sorry could you repeat what pressures on
the PHA exacerbated by uncertainty about
regulatory Arrangements pending the exit
from the European Union
no immediate examples come to mind there
is no doubt however that
their capacity was deflected as
everybody's Wars in terms of trying to
plan and prepare for EU except I can't
think of specific examples in in
response to that I think everybody's
agreed there was an impact
oh absolutely with that without any
question about
thank you very much indeed
Melody that concludes the evidence for
today thank you very much indeed to
Michael thank you for your help
um thank you we may meet again in
Belfast I think we may
uh 10 o'clock tomorrow please
foreign